foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right good let me know
foreign
[Music]
good morning I know
[Music]
okay
foreign
all right are we ready for the jury
yes your honor
okay
okay
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen
all right please we see your next
witness uh good morning your honor uh Mr
Depp calls Kate Moss to the stand
she will be appearing on your screen all
right ma'am can you hear me
one two three four five thank you ma'am
if you could raise your right hand
do you swear for him to tell the truth
on a penalty of law
I can't thank you
good morning Miss Mosser I should say
good afternoon your time your time my
name is Ben Chu from The Firm of brown
Rudnick would you please State your full
name for the record
Kate Smith
Miss Moss where do you reside
London England from where are you
testifying today Miss Moss
um gloucestershire England
Miss moss do you know Johnny Depp
yes I do how do you know Mr Depp
I had a relationship with him
uh did there come a time when you and Mr
Depp had a romantic relationship
yes
for how long this mosque were you and Mr
Depp a romantic couple
from 1993
no 1994 to 1998.
Miss Moss did there come a time when you
uh while you and Mr Depp were a couple
that the two of you took a vacation
together
to the golden eye Resort in Jamaica
yes
what if anything happened when you were
in Jamaica with Mr Depp
I um
we were leaving the room and Johnny left
the room before I did and there had been
a rainstorm and as I left the room I
slid down the stairs
and I hurt my back
how did you and
I apologize Miss Moss please continue
and I screamed because I was in because
I didn't know what had happened to me
and I was in pain and um he came running
back to help me and carried me to my
room and got me medical attention
did Mr Depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no during the course of your
relationship did he ever push you down
any stairs
he never pushed me kicked me
or through Midtown any stairs
Miss Moss have you ever before today
testified in any kind of Court
proceeding
no I have never why did you decide to
testify today objection your honor
of what we just talked about
all right I'll sustain
Ed thank you Miss Moss uh we have
nothing further at this time we greatly
appreciate your taking the time to
testify any cross-examination no your
honor all right you're free to go thank
you Miss Moss thank you very much thank
you
all right your next Witness
your honor we're calling Dr Shannon
Curry
just give us a moment
to move the TV
here
all right Dr Curry
foreign
please call Shannon Curry Dr Shannon
Curry that's fine ma'am you're still
under oath so
please have a seat doctor
good morning
good morning Dr curry good morning can
you remind the jury who you are and what
you do sure I'm Dr Shannon Curry I'm a
clinical and forensic psychologist and
I'm here today to rebut the testimony
that was provided by Dr Hughes
which of the opinions rendered by Dr
Hughes do you intend to rebut so they're
generally speaking there are three main
categories that I'd like to talk about
today so the first is that uh Dr Hughes
misrepresented the tests and the results
that she utilized in her evaluation she
misrepresented my testing and the
results that I obtained in my evaluation
and she communicated in a manner in a
manner provided testimony in a manner
that presented
um essentially her own opinions and the
self-report of Ms heard as facts
okay the first category you talked about
was the misrepresentation of her own
test methods and results what do you
mean by that
so uh Dr Hughes used she stated that she
administered 12 tests
in actuality she used eight checklists
about half of those were symptom
checklists the other half were
checklists checklists about
experiences that people can have with
domestic violence and those are not
appropriate for forensic settings they
are easily exploited
um other issues that you intend to
address relative to misrepresent
misrepresentation of old results yes so
in addition to using these checklist
measures which are easily exploited in a
forensic context they're developed for
research or treatment only
she also stated that these checklists
revealed things that they simply cannot
reveal especially in this context
um
and uh let's see
uh she also misrepresented information
clear indications on several of the
objective measures that she offered and
there were indications visible that Ms
heard had essentially engaged in what we
call response Distortion so clear
indications of exaggeration on one of
the measures that's specific to PTSD
clear minimization of symptoms
intentional on another more broad
personality and psychopathology-based
measure that she gave to misheard which
she did not acknowledge
did you
intend to address anything relative to
the Caps five
I did so uh Dr Hughes administered the
Caps five about ten days after I did
almost two years after she initially
tested misheard
um and she did not administer the test
appropriately so she left major
components blank she didn't apply the
scoring rules that are clearly outlined
with the test and yet she diagnosed her
misheard with PTSD based on that
assessment
what about
Dr hughes's use of the personality
assessment inventory
so of the test that Dr Hughes
administered to would be considered of
those 12 two would be considered what we
call forensically relevant instruments
meaning that they're objective enough
and they provide us with some
information about how the examinee
approached the test that it would be
appropriate for this setting where the
examinee is going to have a natural
incentive to present themselves in a way
that benefits the outcome of their case
now on the Pai there were clear
indications that misheard was responding
and obtained scores in a manner that's
consistent with individuals who have a
personality disorder and there was also
an indication that several scales we
call this a configuration so you might
have one main skill that you notice is
elevated then you look for additional
subscale information to get additional
information on what could be elevating
that scale and there was a configuration
that showed that even though Ms heard
had moderately elevated one of the
skills that can be associated with
trauma
that elevation is better explained by
childhood or distant traumatic
experiences like the complex trauma
misheard reported experiencing growing
up
okay
you said you
that uh
that Dr Hughes utilized checklists that
are not appropriate for forensic
analysis can you explain that
yes so as I said
um in any sort of forensic context
whether it's a civil or criminal matter
a person who's being evaluated is going
to have major incentive to present in a
way that benefits the outcome of their
case so you always approach the
examination I believe Dr Hughes said
with the health healthy dose of
skepticism but that alone is not enough
we have to operationalize that so
um we actually have to administer very
comprehensive objective tests that
either control for attempts to
manipulate the test results or reveal
attempts to manipulate the test results
so that we're not just blindly accepting
the results or the self-report of the
examinee
um how many tests were administered by
Dr Hughes
she said that she administered 12 tests
how many of them were appropriate for
forensic physical examination
so the trauma symptom inventory is
appropriate it's an objective measure
and it does have two primary scales that
look at how the person approached the
test the personality assessment
inventory is an excellent test it is a
Broadband measure meaning that it
captures not only symptoms of Mental
Illness but also General personality
traits that also gives us pretty
detailed skills similar to that one test
I administered the mmpi that tell us a
lot of nuanced information about the way
the person approached the test she also
administered a malingering screen that
can be very very useful but not in this
context so it's called the Miller
forensic assessment symptom test it's a
brief set of questions that you ask the
examinee and it's been shown by research
to be extremely effective at identifying
and examine these attempts to fake a
severe mental illness or psychosis and
psychosis is when somebody loses
complete connection with reality it's
excellent for that purpose it's actually
been shown in the research to not be
effective at all for identifying a
respondent's attempts to fake PTSD
anxiety or mood disorders the questions
are just too odd for somebody who has
the wherewithal to be trying to have
PTSD to endorse they see through it so
she used that
um that's a fine test but not
appropriate for this context
of the various tests that she
administered how many were these
checklists eight of them all right and
what are you talking about specifically
okay
so I had mentioned that there were two
main categories of checklists she used
the first is the symptom checklists
um those included the back depression
inventory it's a brief inventory of
items that essentially show all of the
symptoms of depression that a person
might have and you rate which level of
severity you have for each question she
also gave the back anxiety inventory
very similar but just with questions
about anxiety she gave the mood disorder
questionnaire which is a very brief
again checklist it shows symptoms of
bipolar disorder bipolar disorder is a
mood disorder where you might have an
extended manic episode and then a very
extended depressive episode
um and then she gave the post-traumatic
stress disorder checklist and that is a
screening instrument only
um it contains every single symptom of
PTSD so there's a secondary danger here
too when you think about it given that
PTSD is the most frequently feigned and
claimed diagnosis in civil courts if
you're handing somebody a checklist that
lists every single symptom of PTSD
you're essentially teaching them all the
little nuances that we're looking for to
give that diagnosis so she gave that to
miss Hearn misheard endorsed most of the
items and Dr Hughes diagnosed her with
PTSD and substantiated that opinion by
Ms heard's checking those items on the
pcl5
um
were there another group of
checklists that Dr Hughes used yes so uh
she also and oh and I forgot one on the
last because I don't think of it as one
but
previously I'd explained and I do not
expect you to remember it's called The
Life events checklist which is just an
inventory of experience as a person may
have gone through that are traumatic Dr
Hughes also used that and that's
appropriate to use before The clinician
administered PTSD scale the gold
standard caps five however she
administered this long ago before she
gave the Caps file now that going on to
the second group there were three
checklists that she gave that are
specific to abuse
and the first she gave the danger
assessment scale was actually developed
for use by nursing staff and an
emergency room setting specifically for
female victims of intimate partner
violence the purpose of this is
important because our forensic ethics
our psychology psychology ethics talk a
lot about relevance is the test relevant
to the purpose and the danger assessment
scale its initial purpose was completely
different this was developed to show
high risk factors for dangerousness and
pretty much to help a female who is in
an extremely abusive partnership who is
in the emergency room with extreme
injuries to stop rationalizing because
if she has to check off all the things
that have happened that year that have
been dangerous as the owner Gunn has he
you know I won't go into all of them but
the more she checks off the more likely
it is that she might realize that she is
in imminent danger and then accept
resources offered by the hospital and
social work to protect her that was the
purpose of this scale it was never
intended to be used as a retrospective
measure to look back in time and find
out whether abuse was occurring based on
one person's report years later in a
litigation she also gave the conflict
tactic scale revised the second edition
similarly this scale was developed for
research purposes to research Family
Violence again there is no control for
exaggeration or minimizing it was just
given to research participants
anonymously so that we could get data on
the prevalence of abuse and how abusive
Dynamics were and on that there's 39
questions where the respondent indicates
essentially certain abusive behaviors
they may have engaged in and then 39
where they indicate behaviors their
partner might have engaged in and
obviously you can understand that in a
forensic setting the respondent is
likely to put a very minimal amount of
behaviors they engaged in and then
extremely
increase the number of behaviors their
partner might have and then lastly let's
see I oh the abusive behaviors
observation checklist was the third
checklist she gave this one
has not there's there's no known
research even on its Effectiveness for
what it was developed it's a theoretical
very brief checklist that was meant to
be used for therapy
where an individual who had experienced
domestic violence could
essentially read through some of the
behaviors that constitute violence that
they might not have been aware of
and if those behaviors applied to them
or if some of those coping strategies
were ones they utilized they would check
that off and then they have a way to
talk about it because now it's been put
to words again this is similarly
problematic if you're in a civil
litigation the person's motivated to
have their results be consistent with a
claim or an allegation of intimate
partner violence and an allegation that
they've been severely harmed then they
could simply just check off more and not
only that but checklists like this one
specifically give a lot of nuanced
information about what clinicians might
be looking for when they're assessing
whether violence was present or whether
the person's self-report is consistent
with a genuine self-report of having
been victimized they're given all that
information that we might be looking for
can you talk specifically about Dr
hughes's use of the I think you called
it the pcl5
yes
so the pcl5
is the post-traumatic stress disorder
checklist this is different not to be
confused with the Caps five which I've
talked about previously as being the
gold standard
the pcl5 was developed by the national
Center of PTSD it's intended for
treatment so if I were for instance
working with a service member who I know
had had been in combat I would probably
give this as a standard with my intake
before we do the diagnostic interview it
kind of gives me a read on how somebody
who's there for treatment who we assume
can be taken at their word because if
they give us correct information they're
going to get an appropriate treatment
and if they give us incorrect they might
not get the treatment they need so I
would give this checklist to them and
then if they recognize some of those
symptoms of PTSD they could check it off
and that would probably indicate to me
that I need to then do the next step if
they're checking off more items than not
I would probably decide to administer
the clinician-administered PTSD scale
that gold standard interview to find out
more about a diagnosis the last thing is
what everybody refers to is the Caps
five
yes the Caps five
what about
um well you talked about forensic use
what do you mean by that
so when I'm talking about uh forensic
evaluation that's an evaluation that
doesn't isn't done for therapy or
treatment it's specifically to assist
the fact finder to assist the judge or
the jury in the court by providing
information about the psychological
status about an individual and that's an
important delineation too we are not
psychologists I wish we were mind
readers I wish we had a crystal ball and
could find out whether intimate partner
violence occurred and look back in the
past but it's nothing like that really
uh it's a lot less interesting we look
at data we have to control for those
response biases and then we also are
looking at functioning which
is really the bottom line of the
assessment did the person have a change
in functioning from before the alleged
trauma or in this case the alleged ipv
to after is there a decline in the way
they're going about their lives
we approach all right
foreign
Dr Curry
um
let's look back at uh
some of those domestic violence
checklists that you were talking about
okay
and um
did you see any problem with the use of
those
yes what problems did you see well uh
doctor first of all they shouldn't be
used so we do have Professional
Standards that require that we utilize
instruments that are relevant and
appropriate for the particular setting
and that we substantiate our opinions
Based on data that is reliable from
tested accurate reliable tests for the
purpose so there's that it's
inconsistent with the ethics and
essentially they they just shouldn't be
used they don't provide us with the
robust information that it would be
expected in such a high-stakes setting
foreign
would you have expected Dr Hughes to
comment on the
limitations of the checklist she was
using yes so uh first of all
uh Dr Hughes provided opinions based on
these checklists so she referenced
especially the danger assessment scale
several times throughout her testimony
stating that Ms hurt was in a very
dangerous situation
we also have an ethical guideline and a
professional standard as well that
indicate that whenever there is question
about the reliability and the validity
and in Psychology we use the term
validity to talk about accuracy of any
of the methods that we're using to
collect data we clearly communicate not
only that there are limitations to our
opinions but we also need to provide the
fact finder with information about what
the potential implications or impact
could actually be so for instance if we
use a scale that's idiosyncratic for the
purpose but we would first need to
explain why we made that decision to not
follow standard procedure years and then
we would need to explain the use of this
skill might introduce some potential
exaggeration of this symptom and and so
I'm trying to control for that that way
but that was one of the limitations of
my opinion you have to make it very
clear transparency is really at the
center of good science in general
um
boring response Distortion what is
response distortion response Distortion
is a term that speaks generally about an
examinee approaching a test and
providing answers that are either
exaggerated or minimized but in some way
an inaccurate representation of their
current mental status or their
experience
what
what test do you believe that Dr Hughes
failed to acknowledge response
distortion on
so she administered the personality
assessment inventory which is similar to
the test I gave them mmbi to it's that
General Broadband measure of
Psychopathology symptoms and personality
traits it includes several scales that
are very good at detecting either
exaggeration minimization or even trying
to claim that you have unusually good
qualities on that test there were clear
indicators that Ms heard very similar to
the way she approached my M MPI engaged
in defensiveness and in fact there's a
function that you can look at so you
have that main scale elevation we call
it positive impression management was
elevated and then because we want to
make sure that somebody isn't elevating
that scale just because they have such
well-being there are additional
configurations of scales that you can
look at to find out what's going on and
so the Casual discriminant function is
uh sort of the name of one of these
configurations these uh equations that
are done and she was highly elevated on
that in fact that elevation tells you
that no this isn't accidental this isn't
because she's just doing so well in life
that she is an extremely extremely low
amount of problems no this is an
intentional over reporting or I'm sorry
an intentional effort to minimize any uh
appearance of having problems
now you may have addressed this but
there was a reference to malingering yes
so what's interesting about Ms heard's
approach to different tests is that it
seems to be influenced by what we call
the face validity of questions on the
test so if a test looks like it's
measuring PTSD
you see exaggeration on her validity
scales if the test has less face valid
questions for instance the personality
assessment which Dr Hughes administered
mmpi to which I administered where she
can't quite figure out what the
questions are asking they seem really
banal in General on those you see
extreme defensiveness minimization of
any potential pathology essentially
presenting herself as perfect and free
of any mental illness or personality
disorder but on the trauma symptom
inventory which Dr Hughes administered
that was the one that I previously
indicated for ease of explanation when
the test results come out for how the
person approaches the test that test
itself prints it as a percentage and
there's a really excellent scale for
finding out if a person is exaggerating
their symptoms of PTSD it's called the
atypical response scale and the TSI 2 is
the revised version of this test and
that scale was improved this time around
to really
try to be a clean indication of is this
person exaggerating and it it puts quite
High questions in the test that are so
unusual they might sound like PTSD but
even the most severe cases of PTSD don't
have these symptoms and so somebody
who's intentionally trying to exaggerate
PTSD or possibly unintentionally but
nonetheless who's exaggerating it is
likely to endorse these items even
though they're not real PTSD symptoms
misheard scored so highly on this that
even if there is although Dr Hughes
correctly said there tends to be a
negative skew when people have the high
levels of distress that's associated
with PTSD so sometimes people score
higher on this even when they do a PTSD
she scored so high that that is
effectively rolled out as a possibility
okay
um
what about Dr hughes's Administration
and use of the Caps five
okay yes so Dr Hughes had diagnosed
misheard with PTSD back in 2019 when she
began testing her it wasn't until two
years later more than two years later
ten days after I administered the Caps 5
with Ms heard that Dr Hughes held an
impromptu evaluation session remotely
with Ms heard and administered the Caps
five she had previously diagnosed PTSD
without using what we consider to be the
gold standard PTSD diagnostic interview
and again when we're doing a forensic
evaluation it is an important
responsibility and part of our ethics
and Professional Standards are that we
document everything to allow for
transparency and full judicial scrutiny
and Dr Hughes administered incorrectly
she left huge sections very relevant
sections blank there's no way to
understand why she scored it as high as
she did based on the information that's
provided you're essentially supposed to
notate the examinees responses as
verbatim as possible to explain your
reasoning and implying their scoring
procedure it's a standardized test and
if you don't follow those standard
procedures it's completely invalid not
only that but AF it looks as though Dr
Hughes further invalidated it by trying
to show that she had assessed for the
childhood trauma impact and it's she had
said that she went back and asked the
childhood question but you can't do that
if you're assessing for two separate
periods of one's life to find out the
relatedness to PTSD you do two separate
caps interviews period you don't create
your own question system that is
non-standard administration of the tests
and it invalidates it
you also mentioned with respect to the
Pai or the personality assessment
inventory that Dr Hughes failed to
mention
some elements once you fail to mention
oh okay so on the personality assessment
inventory so first she failed to mention
that there was it were clear indications
of response Distortion she also failed
to mention that uh Ms heard scored in
her score profile against their main
scores she did elevate a score for the
borderline personality disorder sort of
section but that in and of itself would
not indicate a diagnosis however the
configuration ever scores overall is
consistent with that and in fact it's
one of this diagnostic suggestions given
by the test itself and then also there's
a configuration around Ms Hertz trauma
responses on that particular test which
demonstrates that it is more likely that
those symptoms were reported in relation
to Something in the distant childhood
it's more consistent with childhood
chronic abuse than present circumstances
or recent circumstances
okay I think you said in addition to
the the issues with their own testing uh
Dr Hughes misrepresented your results
she did can you tell us how
so what I would say the main issue was
that she said that Ms heard obtained a
normal profile on my mmpi too
how do you disagree with uh Dr Hughes
relative to the profile okay so the
profile was not normal so Ms hurt
already had subtle elevations just by
the the test by itself as it came out
there were subtle elevations but they
were elevations that
if the validity skills hadn't been as
elevated as they were you might have
said this person has some traits but
this isn't necessarily at the level of a
true pathology however misheard elevated
a scale that essentially is a
defensiveness scale on this test and
when you're giving this test you always
are mindful of different Norms or groups
who may have similar profiles and there
are certain groups of litigants who tend
to elevate this scale as well so I had
that in mind however misheard elevated
this so much that it was far beyond the
mean for the the litigants that are
known to have the highest levels of this
scale this defensiveness scale and when
this scale is elevated to the level that
it is you automatically understand that
it is very likely that those clinical
skills we I keep doing this because I'm
seeing it in my head it looks like sort
of uh an ECT it's sort of these Peaks
you see on a graph and when you see
these Peaks and you have this huge Peak
over here for the defensiveness scale
what you know is that these Peaks are
artificially they've been lowered or
suppressed based on the respondent being
so defensive they still detected what's
likely there for her but it's not as
high as it should be so you make an
adjustment and the recommendation is
that anything at 60 or above we call it
a t score of 60 or above is considered
significant Miss herds were already over
60 some were quite higher than that and
then you see a very clear profile and
that was how I got that I had mentioned
a 3-6 code Type now the test does its
own correction also for some of the
scores but not the ones that are her
main code type with the test correction
she had a 136 code Type which is very
similar
what is a 3 6 code Type
a 3 6 code type is something that has
been researched and bound to be highly
correlated or probabilistic of certain
behavioral Tendencies and personality
traits and the traits with the 3 6 code
Type tend to be marked by a lot of
externalization of blame a lot of denial
about one's own personal faults
intentional or not intentional but just
extreme denial hostility that is
strongly controlled and suppressed the
person may not even realize how hostile
they are they are but family members
those closest to them are very likely to
report that they lose their temper and
when they lose their temper it explodes
uh we have sort of what we call a
cookbook for these code types which in
it will provide you with all the
information that's been researched to be
associated with them and our cookbook
actually states that that 3 6 profile
specifically tends to be associated with
cruel and ruthless Behavior particularly
to those who they perceive as less
powerful than them and subordinates
that you did that you went through
relative to the mmpi
so uh
I conducted a very methodical analysis
of the scores I do this for every test
and I also did it when I was reviewing
Dr hughes's scores so what you haven't
seen that's in Discovery is that I
created a 25-page outline just of her
scores with uh and it's sort of a table
so I'll put the score I'll do it in
sections so that I can understand
different groupings different research
studies and I start with looking at all
the validity scales so I put in the
score I put and I'll even color the
table to show me if it's kind of in the
high Zone moderate zone or low and then
if it's low is it a significant low
score or is it just low so it doesn't
mean anything and then I in the right
side I put all the research data that I
found on this particular scale score and
so I start with the validity scales the
way the person approached the test then
I go down to essentially we call these
is the first Factor so their overall
sense of well-being and how well they
cope on this actually misheards
she endorsed scores or endorsed items
that were the opposite of PTSD so really
saying that she feels free of distress
and that she views herself very well so
then I go down to control self-control
loss of control coping abilities and I
put in the scores that are associated
with that and the research and the test
development then I go down to clinical
and personality pathology and I look at
all the scores that are significant
there first with the top level main
scores then with all of the different
sub scores again citing the research the
meaning the level of elevation and what
that means and then I do comparison with
different research groups so for Ms
heard I did a section that looked at all
sorts of different scores that have been
implicated with a PTSD presentation to
see if any of those were consistent
I I can't remember how many there were I
think I put 13 on there but I could be
wrong uh but I believe that there was
only one that could even be in some
research is sometimes associated with it
but it was general anxiety which turned
out to be more trait specific I looked
at the scores that are typical of women
with ipv hers were not consistent at all
with those I looked at the scores that
were consistent with people who are
frequently in litigation hers actually
were very highly correlated with those
that tend to be also consistent with a 3
6 code type and the reason for that is
believed to be that they tend to
perceive themselves often as victims who
need to avenge wrongs
were there
other results
you believe Dr Hughes to have
misrepresented
for instance whatever the TSI 2.
yes
um so Dr Hughes
generally said that testing supported
PTSD and that there was an etiology for
her trauma of intimate partner violence
she did reference that uh essentially
the I can't remember if she said that
the trauma symptom inventory indicated
PTSD but she did say that the elevation
on that validity scale is consistent
with PTSD and that's simply not true
that scale was designed and has been
tested and shown to be there to show
when somebody is endorsing extremely
unusual items that are not consistent
with PTSD and even though when some
people are experiencing PTSD their
distress level is so high that they'll
engage in what we call a pride for help
and they may sometimes exaggerate
distress again when you're looking at
scores as high as misheards and then
you're not seeing indications of PTSD in
the more subtle tests where she doesn't
know what she's endorsing
there's it's good evidence that her over
endorsement on that one test
um is because of the reason the scale
was made to detect exaggeration and
feigning of symptoms
resulted in the 98 percentile score
yes on that square on that atypical
response scale and what is that 90
percentile score to represent
so that 98th percentile score just
represents that among 98 98 of people
who take that test would not have
endorsed
she scored more of those unusual items
that are not consistent with PTSD than
98 of people who have ever taken that
test
does that relate to this concept you
talked about before called feigning yes
what is feigning again well feigning is
essentially exaggerating symptoms of a
disorder
all right
um I think the third thing you indicated
you were going to talk about was uh
self-reports and personal opinion as
facts what are you talking about there
so in any science and in Psychology
specifically it's really important that
we use precise language and we say what
we mean and we do not present opinions
as facts because when you are in the
role of an expert witness
um
or an expert in any setting essentially
a lay person may not be able to detect
the difference between something that is
a personal opinion that you're giving
versus something that is substantiated
by research data test data reliable test
methods so our ethics talk about
especially the specialty guidelines of
forensic psychology the responsibility
we have to distinguish between data
then inferences we're making from that
data what the data can mean sort of like
those tables I do I put the data the
inferences based on the research and
then what my ultimate opinion is
integrating all of that data and it's
very important that we clarify that to
the fact finder to the judge the jury
that's our responsibility that we do not
cloak personal opinions or the
self-report of an examinee as an expert
Factor somehow scientifically based when
it is just a personal opinion or
self-report of an examinee what do you
mean by self-report
the self-report is essentially what the
examinee tells you during the interview
she did this most when describing
instances of alleged ipv and there's
also an issue there because one of our
ethics also discusses the importance of
relevance and withholding essentially
constraining Our Testimony to the data
and not including private information
personal information that unnecessarily
compromises the Dignity of any of the
litigants she provided a lot of what
was Ms heard's report to her the
allegations of abuse when describing Mr
Depp who she had not examined when
describing Mr Depp's Behavior his
motivations I believe she used the word
obsessive jealousy quite a few times
talked about misheard being in a highly
dangerous situation these are simply
things that we cannot detect based on
testing and a psychological evaluation
we have to evaluate the person we have
to get consent and we can only describe
an individual not whether or not ipv has
occurred and we certainly shouldn't go
into explicit details about sexual
encounters or other things that are
highly prejudicial shocking and hard to
forget
um Dr Hughes says that misheard has PTSD
do you agree I do not why not
the results of my multi-method
comprehensive evaluation based on
carefully selected researched relevant
test test instruments based on comparing
those instruments to misheard
self-report observing Ms heard's
Behavior over 12 direct hours of
assessment reviewing copious notes from
prior therapists who indicated symptoms
in their notes reviewing the notes of
nurse fellati previously nurse aurum who
spent I believe at one point almost two
months with Ms heard daily
reviewing the notes of her treating
providers uh let's see all of the legal
documents and discovery
there was no evidence of PTSD
how is evidence of
PT generally
so really the bottom line in a forensic
psychological evaluation is a change in
functioning that's what we're looking
for again I said we don't have a crystal
ball we're not Wizards we can't get into
somebody's head what we're looking for
where they're identifiable changes in
the way the person engaged in their
world were they able to keep a job at
PTSD is an extremely disabling diagnosis
when a person has true PTSD it is
difficult for them to work you'll see
unemployment job loss it causes extreme
levels of distress and impairment
there's divorce there's isolation and
estrangement from children from family
members
extreme alcohol abuse often a string of
sudden DUIs when the person never had
any before they become homebound they
can't go to the store they're certainly
not going to events they're not having
success in their film career usually
they're not exercising every day
pursuing their Hobbies being Avid
readers obtaining level 3 simile
training having dinner parties with
friends speaking to public groups those
are just indications of very high
functioning and when you're looking for
a decrease in functioning over time that
is inconsistent with that decrease
what about Dr hughes's suggestion that
Mr waldman's statements served as a
trigger for Ms heard's PTSD
all right
Dr Houston suggested that perhaps Ms
Hertz PTSD was somehow triggered
what's your view on that
I would say that it can't be triggered
if PTSD isn't present
thank you very much doctor all right
cross-examination thank you
Dr Curry I just want to make sure that
we all remember you're not board
certified correct no I'm not okay and
you've been licensed for how long I've
been licensed for 10 years okay and you
are being paid by Mr Depp's legal team
to be here correct yes how much have you
charged so far I actually don't know
over a hundred thousand I truly don't
know I don't do my own books over two
hundred thousand
I don't know
over three hundred thousand that would
be way too much but I do not know okay
um now just so that we all remember
you had dinner
at Mr Depp's house
for three to four hours with Mr Depp Mr
Waltman Mr Chu and Ms Vasquez correct I
was interviewed I asked if there was
anything I could eat because in about
three hours I started to get hungry Mr
Depp then offered to order takeout for
the entire team
so you had dinner with Miss at Mr Depp's
home with Mr Waldman Mr Chu Ms Vasquez
and Mr Dow correct
yes and you had drinks as well correct I
actually don't know I do remember that
there were drinks do you recall
testifying earlier that you did have a
drink of mule something no I remember
testifying that there might have been a
mule
a Moscow Mule okay thank you we didn't
have animals there as well right no
animal okay that's good to know and and
you talked about transparency I just
want to make sure you had several uh
designations expert designations and
reports in this case correct yes and
then not one of them did you disclose
that you had dinner and drinks at Mr
Depp's house for three to four hours
with Mr Waldman Mr Chu and Ms Vasquez is
that correct Ms bettahof you're
mischaracterizing what occurred Dr Curry
please answer the question not once did
you disclose this in any of your reviews
I did not disclose that I was
interviewed as that standard procedure
but it's true that you have never gone
to a client's house to be interviewed
for an expert witness position correct
yes because I never had a client that
was essentially homebound because of
their Celebrity Status all right and and
you talked to Mr Depp for three to four
hours
uh before taking on the role of
assessing misheard and deciding whether
she was suffering from any distress
correct I did not talk to Mr Depp I was
talking to his legal team and he was
there to observe
he was present for the three to four
hours and are you saying now he just
stayed silent and said nothing all day I
don't recall what he didn't or didn't do
I was answering questions okay now your
expertise here is limited to whether
Amber Heard suffers from PTSD currently
is that correct yes I was tasked with
conducting an evaluation to determine
miser's mental status very very strict
time limitations because we've promised
to get this case to the jury so I'd
really appreciate if you just answer my
question rather than trying to go for
sure okay thank you very much now
after you did had the dinner
you then provided the designation in
February of 2021. in which you said and
this is long before you ever saw Amber
Heard correct you said that Amber Heard
quote exhibits patterns of behavior that
are consistent with co-occurring cluster
B personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder end of
quote correct no no you we went through
this before we did but and and that was
on the designation was it not
I I told you last time that I did not
write that okay and you don't know who
did on the legal team correct no okay
and then I also asked you if you may
recall whether you listened to the audio
recording in which Mr Depp taunted Amber
Heard that she had a borderline
personality disorder do you recall that
I recall you asking me that yes did you
recall listening to that audio
I don't recall Mr Depp taunting Miss
heard I do recall that he at some point
suggested she might have that diagnosis
okay and that was back in these audio
tapes back when they were together
correct
yes okay now you've never before been
asked to testify or serve as an expert
with respect to someone who has bipolar
disorder correct no as I previously
stated that's not true all right
[Music]
that's not up here anymore
you're on can we approach it all right
yes
now you recall testifying in your
deposition on March 21 2022 correct yes
and you were under oath at that time
correct yes and the question I just
showed you on page 207 line five have
you ever been asked to testify or serve
as an expert with respect to whether
someone has bipolar disorder and your
answer at that time was no correct yes
I'd forgotten that case okay
have you ever been has to testify
whether anyone has Behavioral or
characterological conduct that suggests
they may be an ipv perpetrator
I can't I may have it's difficult after
about 250 cases it's difficult to
remember specifically all right and have
you ever been
and have you ever been qualified to
testify as an expert in domestic abuse
or violence
violent oh domestic abuse or violence
yes that's been a component of testimony
can I take a look
okay
line 16 of page 207 have you ever been
qualified as an expert in the area of
ipv your answer on line 20 was no under
oath correct then the next question have
you ever been qualified to testify as an
expert in domestic abuse or violence
that and goes into page 208 line four
the answer then under oath was no
now
you would agree that the literature is
quite clear that trauma-based symptoms
such as PTSD are complex PTSD have
symptoms that overlap with borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder yes yes okay and
you would agree that it's important to
use valid and reliable measures for an
accurate diagnosis correct absolutely
okay you chose however not to administer
the structured clinical interview for
DSM-5 personality disorders the skin is
that correct I did okay and would you
agree that that is a state-of-the-art
structured clinical interview
not for a forensic evaluation with a
sophisticated examinee but to determine
if a personality disorder is present no
not in this setting you don't agree with
that I do not you don't agree that that
is the gold standard assessment for
Reliable accurate psychiatric diagnosis
it's a good one but for treatment
settings especially okay
now did Ms heard you said you talked
about you read
on records right
yes okay do you recall reading the
treatment records for the psychologist
Bonnie Jacobs who saw Amber Heard over
five years I do and did you see anything
in Bonnie Jacobs notes over five years
in which she diagnosed Miss heard with
borderline personality or histrionic
personality disorder no now you also saw
the notes of Dr
Connell Cohen correct and you even
attended his deposition correct yes all
right and he saw Amber for roughly two
years he was part of the Dr Kipper
connection right
yes okay and did you see anything in Dr
Collins notes
um and did he say in his deposition that
he diagnosed Amber Heard with borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder I saw the symptoms
clearly delineated throughout his notes
and in his deposition he does not use
diagnoses so he would not have diagnosed
her he said specific
Ally in his deposition he did not
diagnose her with that correct yes and
he also specifically stated that he does
not use diagnoses all right and you also
have seen Dr Banks Dr Amy Banks the
psychiatrist of her deposition correct
yes diagnostic deposition I reviewed her
notes in the transcript all right did Dr
Anderson diagnose Ms heard with
borderline personality disorder or as a
histrionic personality disorder I don't
believe she provided any diagnosis since
she was a couple's therapist all right
now you've said quite a bit about Don
Hughes but do you remember how many
years of experience Don Hughes has in
ipv and domestic abuse and violence I
know it's quite a bit extensive and she
is board certified correct yes she is
all right and she spent 29 hours of
examination with Amber Heard she did she
not
yes mostly interviewing all right and
she admitted and She interviewed her
therapists Bonnie Jacobs and Colin
Cowell correct yes and she also
interviewed Amber's late mother
yes okay and she administered 12
different tests over the period of that
time correct well as I said the majority
of those were checklists which are
inappropriate for the forensic setting I
I understand that's what you say but she
administered 12 different tests correct
if you want to qualify them as tests
sure okay
okay and so you
five and PTSD now you assessed Ms
heard's traumas in her life correct
uh yes I did I give her an instrument to
assess for any trauma exposure
throughout the entire lifespan yes yes
it's fine
as sexual assaults by Mr Depp more than
satisfied this requirement did you not
write that in your notes
that is not what I wrote in my notes do
you have my notes ministered a
structured clinical interview based on
that trauma correct
not exactly it's not quite right
now Dr Hughes administered a full
intimate partner violence assessment
correct
that's not a psychological assessment we
can't assess for intimate partner
violence that's an event Dr Hughes
administered a full intimate partner
violence assessment she stated that and
that's actually something I'm reporting
today okay and you really
I sure did yes okay and are you aware
that in September 2019 Ms heard had a
trauma-based symptom on many of those
valid tests
um can you be a little bit more specific
many of those valid tests which tests
are you talking about do you have a
recollection of that September 2019
she administered all of her testing in
September 2019 so I'm not sure which one
oh except for the Caps five which was 10
days after mine in 2021. now Dr Hughes
clinically evaluated those symptoms and
established that Ms Hurd does have PTSD
from the totality of the intimate
partner violence by Mr Depp correct
that's what she stated yesterday
now Dr Anderson's clinical notes that
said Amber had come to objection hearsay
I haven't even asked the question yet
are you going to read her notes well let
me no no actually I I wasn't going to
return that I was going to ask a
particular question you talked about
danger do you recall that in your
testimony yes all right now if if a
patient comes to you as a couple's
therapist with two black eyes
would you assess there that there may be
a potential danger there
sure okay okay did you read Dr
Anderson's notes
I believe I did
now you administered the Minnesota
multiphasic personality inventory too
the mmpi2 do you recall that yes and you
use that to determine whether Amber had
PTSD right it not by itself but it was a
part of the data okay
quote deliberate attempts to mislead our
uncommon common end quote isn't that
correct sorry could you repeat that
in the t-score section of that
for which assesses deliberate attempts
to mislead
do you recall she scored a 60 on that
test correct so there are multiple
t-scores for at each scale so I'm not
sure which scale you're talking about
okay
well we can deal with that later so you
would agree that you need to follow
ethics and best practices in forensic
psychology correct yes okay and the two
primary sources are the American
Psychological Association ethical
principles and professional code of
conduct right and the American
Psychological association's specialty
guidelines for forensic psychology
correct yes and Specialty guidelines
1.02 states that forensic practitioners
quote strive for accuracy impartiality
fairness and Independence correct yes
okay and Specialty guidelines 1.03
states that you have to avoid a conflict
of interest yes
no
in addition
to not listing the four hours you've
spent with Mr Depp Mr Waldman Mr Chu and
Ms Vasquez you also did not list that
you spent an hour with Dr Shaw correct
that's incorrect
you say that you that the designation
said that you during my deposition I
also clarified this I didn't spend an
hour with Dr Shaw there was an
introduction with the attorneys present
on Zoom
my time on that call was less than 30
minutes okay
close it did you in your in your reports
no
no
I've been asked to testify about Ms
heard's behavior in the context of her
relationship with Mr Depp is that
correct
I was asked to testify about somebody's
behavioral mental status in general so
that can include behavior and involved
in a relationship with Mr Depp but not
specifically
can can you pull up day 10
of uh the trial testimony at page 2710
2710 lines 12 through 18.
may we approach all right
anyway
thank you
Thank you Lisa great job
foreign
does the witness also have okay yep so
Dr Curry this is your testimony from day
10 in this case and if you can look at
page 2710
um line 13. now is it your my question
was now is it your testimony under oath
today that you have not been asked to
testify concerning Ms heard's behavior
in the context of her relationship with
Mr Depp including any abuse
and your answer under oath to this jury
that day was that's correct yes correct
I still agree with that to that question
all right and you have not made any
determinations including any opinions
the misheard abuse Mr Depp or Mr deaf
reviews Miss heard correct correct okay
and and in fact you said that's outside
the scope yes okay of psychology and you
cannot testify whether Amber Heard
suffered any emotional distress as a
result of any of the defamatory comments
that she has alleged Mr Waldman made
through Mr deck or Mr Depp made through
Mr Waldman correct objection your honor
do you want me to read my response sure
objection
that's okay what's the objection are you
on approach okay
now
you have not rendered any open opinion
as to whether Amber Heard exhibits
patterns of behavior that would suggest
her allegations of abuse against Mr Depp
are false would you agree
no I mean yes I would agree with that
thank you and you have not
that's all I've got up for the questions
all right redirect
you were asked about
about the skid
yes what's that
it's a structured clinical interview
it's for rendering a diagnosis it's best
for treatment because you're asking
direct questions of the examinee and
about symptoms so if you have an
examinee who has a tendency to minimize
you're not going to get much information
why didn't you use it because uh well
first of all I had a limited amount of
time for my evaluation and I already had
to
use just to complete the interview was
extremely time consuming
um and I had to even restructure it into
handouts so that I could keep misheard
on track I determined based on that so
this is where you would make an
inference so because I was having
difficulty getting direct answers to my
questions from Ms heard I had determined
that creating forms of those questions
would be a better use of the time which
it was and then I further deduced that
adding on the structured clinical
interview would probably be unproductive
given that I had limited time and needed
to use the best most reliable methods
for getting information in that time
you were asked about the APA specialty
guidelines yes specifically
1.02 and 1.03 have you complied with
them I have
no further questions thank you
thank you Dr Curry you can have a seat
in the corner you're going to go thank
you ma'am
all right Lisa let's go ahead and take
our morning recess for 15 minutes do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay
foreign
just for planning purposes Sammy asked
Mr Tobin to be here as early as noon
just in case with the fluid of the trial
I'm not sure what time we get to that
motion so
okay just to let you know
they need to work on that they're going
to find out who the next witness is
um so let's go ahead and take a recess
until 10 55 okay all right thank you
all right
all right are we ready for the jury uh
no you're honor we we do have a issue
we'd like to write okay sure
all right your next Witness
I'm sorry let's get the jury first right
all right you ready for the jury
thank you
all right thank you
are you ready for the next witness or do
you want us we call uh Mr duck okay
foreign
so just a reminder your cylinder oats
okay yes yes all right thank you sir
good morning Mr death good morning
um we heard
a lot about some statements that Mr
Waldman made do you remember that yes
and Mr Waldman
is your attorney or was your attorney
yes
could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 1245
and this is already an Evidence so
permission to please yes publish
if we could scroll down to the second
page
foreign
do you see the statement here attributed
to Mr Waldman
yes I do
when's the first time that you saw this
statement
we can pull these visit back up thank
you
Mr Depp when is the first time that you
saw this statement by Mr Waldman
um the first time that I ever saw this
statement uh
was in August
um it was when the peace was the the
um
when she August 2020 when I was counter
sued by misheard
this is the first time that I saw any of
these statements
can we please pull up Defenders
defendant's exhibit 12 46.
and this is also already in evidence
thank
you scroll down to the second page
or the third perhaps thank you
Mr Depp do you see this statement that's
attributed to Mr Waldman here
I do
and when is the first time that you saw
these statements
same
counter suit was filed
and could we please go to defense
exhibit 1247.
and again this is already an Evidence
if we could scroll down please thank you
Mr Depp do you see the statement
attributed to Mr Waldman I do indeed yes
and when's the first time that you saw
this statement
the the disability is the same it's the
counterclaim to August 2020.
after you saw these statements for the
first time did you form an understanding
as to where they appeared
as to where they had appeared these
statements in what publication
um
no off the bat I didn't know exactly
[Music]
um
it just seemed like a lot of word salad
to me
I didn't know where they'd come from or
I mean where they ended up or
Mr
do you ring that she you did not assist
her in getting her role in Aquaman
uh yes I do yes
and what is your response to that
[Music]
it's not it's not um it's not exactly
true
do you know when misheard first
auditioned for Aquaman
as I do another day because
um
I was scheduled
uh with um my band the uh the the
Hollywood vampires uh we had done two
shows at the
Roxy which is a place in Los Angeles
to
um rehearse for a uh we were invited to
play at the Rock and reel
um concert which is a huge rock and roll
Festival so we did the two shows to go
to Rio
and play there
um
Mr uh I probably wanted to come with me
and uh
Whitney her sister had come as well
um while we were there in
Rio we were rehearsing getting ready for
the show
uh Mr Ed informed me that she would have
to be going she would have to get back
to Los Angeles for an audition
meaning
um
it's basically after our two hour show
or whatever we had to we would have to
get on the plane immediately to make it
back to Los Angeles
um for this audition
and that audition was uh
at Warner Brothers it was
whatever film it was and when were you
performing at the Rock In Rio oh sorry
yeah that was the
believe it was the 24th of September
in what year oh that was 15.
what do you understand happened after a
misheard audition for Aquaman
um
after after Ms herd's uh
audition or possibly auditions
for Warner Brothers and
I suppose the creative team
um
expressed to me that the
film was going to be Warner Brothers had
said this the film is going to be
shooting in Australia
and Australia was a for miss her that
was a potential
problem which Jackson your honor
let me approach okay
I apologize Mr duck could you please
continue what happened after misheard
auditioned for Aquaman
uh shh I was informed by Mr that the
film was going to be
um shooting in Australia
and
that that was of
concerned to her
and because there it was of concern
um to Warner Brothers
um
so she asked if I would
because I I had a I'd had a multi
um
for a few years I've had a multi-film
deal with with Warner Brothers and uh so
we'd been in business together so I knew
these people had been in I've been on
films with them
so I she asked me if I would speak to
them
I made a phone call and I I spoke to
Jackson here say your honor
I I don't believe he said anything he I
think he was going to say who he spoke
to all right we'll see overruled at this
point okay
um
I spoke to three
um the three upper echelon
um Disney executive excuse me warner
Executives Kevin sujihara Sue Crowell
and uh Craig Silverstein
um
and I
told them that action your honor hearsay
all right I'll just take the rejection
next question
um what was the result of you speaking
with those individuals
[Music]
um
well I I I
can only say that ultimately she did she
did get the job in the film
so hopefully I I I suppose I had curbed
their
worries to some degree
Mr Depp do you recall Miss heard
testifying that she saw you consume
eight to ten MDMA pills while you're at
once while you were in Australian
um March of 2015. yes I do remember that
how many did you remember saying that I
took a handful objection beyond the
scope sorry I just that was extra resume
oh sustain the objection next question
how many times have you done MDMA in
your life Mr death
actually not many not that many times I
would say in my lifetime Maybe
in my lifetime MDMA
six seven maybe and how much MDMA have
you done on those occasions
well not enough to um
not enough to
uh
probably
well not not enough to properly properly
experience the what the um
chemicals are supposed to
do to you
have you ever consumed eight to ten MDMA
pills at once
no no no I have not and why is that
um
because I'd be dead I'm pretty sure I'd
be dead
um
I think one would die yes and
probably rather quickly
Mr dab I'd like to show you some
pictures from the home in Australia that
Miss heard testified about sure could we
please pull up defendants exhibit 1817
which is already in evidence
foreign
do you recognize what's depicted in this
photograph
uh yes I do that's the um that's the
downstairs bar
um of the house we rented in Australia
and can you please show the jury where
you were sitting when misheard through
um the two vodka bottles at you
foreign
if I touch this thing we'll make a yes
well okay so
this chair
that one here was over here
and and it was in pretty much when I was
turned around toward they were all
swivel so when I was turned around
towards the bar I'm facing the bar when
I turned around this way the chair this
chair here was in uh pretty much exactly
this same position as this chair it was
fake when I was facing
um miss her
who was
let's say she was if you're looking at
the photograph she would be about here
could you uh draw a line in the
direction where Miss heard was relative
to where you were sitting yes absolutely
so
if I'm sitting here
um
she was over here
back here
approximately how far away from miss her
from you was misheard if you can recall
I would say I would say it was probably
10 12 15 feet Maybe
10 feet 12 feet
approximately where was your hand when
the vodka bottle hit it
[Music]
um
it was leaning
my arm was sorry my arm was leaning on
the um
The Marble Bar
um
right there with that the imaginary see
this
and leaning
and it kind of just leaned back and and
um
looking at Miss heard she just walked
away with the second bottle
I mean she walked this way when she
threw the first bottle which is
actually visible
the floor
could you please Circle where the first
bottle is
all that is the um
exploded first bottle
that that went past my it went past my
head
and the second bottle
um
hit
right up here where my hand was resting
on the um
marble ball
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
1820.
Mr Depp do you recognize what's depicted
in this photograph
this is the
very bored
and what do you see on the floor in this
picture
and I see what looks to me like a
some kind of napkin it looks uh
solid soiled
blood I don't know and I see glass in
the
Corner blood obviously on the
floor and a towel
leaning upon
some cow something
do you know how that Bloody tissue got
on the floor
[Music]
um
I my best guess
um objection calls for speculation
um do you know how the blood got on the
floor Mr debb I'm pretty well I know how
the blood got on the floor it came from
my dripping finger
so that's why the tissue
um
is is uh
I'm
99.9 sure since it is looks like he's
got blood on it as well is what what I
um
held my finger to help held my finger
with
do you see the wall to the on the left
side of the photograph
I do
was there a wall mounted phone on that
wall
on the left side of the photo
no I didn't uh no
not that I recall now
uh could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 394 which is already in evidence
yes ma'am
Mr debb do you recognize this text
message
I yeah I do
and what what is this message
um
it's a it's a text to Dr Kipper
um
I'm sorry just reading through
yeah this is um
this is my text to the to to
Dr Kipper who who had just happened to
be in town
um telling him that uh
I've had it and that
I just lost a finger fingertip
how long after your finger had been
injured did you send this text message
if you can recall
it's hard to tell because I'm going to
look at the time stamp it's
it's delivered 3 7 2015 5 o'clock
um but I know that because of Australia
time
it was the eighth
and it was probably this was
the whole thing lasted probably until
about 2 p.m
um or so when when that was when Kipper
was called Jerry was brought in and
Jerry judge sorry excuse me
so do you have an estimate as to how
long after your finger had actually been
injured that you sent this message
I I don't think it was very long I think
it was probably
within the next it was you know I'm sure
it was in the next half hour or
so
um I would have had to sneak into a a
bathroom lock myself into
type this out
how were you able to send this text
message to Dr Kipper in the state that
you were in
um
well he wasn't available at the time so
um
is to sort of thumb your way through
don't you
how long after sending this text message
did you see Dr Kipper
um I I don't recall that I think it took
them probably for 30 minutes for
more between 30 to 40 minutes to get
there
what did Dr Kipper do when he first
arrived at the home
oh the first thing he wanted to do is
inspect uh the damage of my finger
um
and try and
figure out exactly what had happened how
it happened
and what did you tell Dr Kipper about
how your finger had been injured
objection your honor
yeah we appreciate it I discussed this
several times
foreign
Mr Depp when Dr Kipper was treating your
finger what did you tell him about how
your finger became injured
um
I told him I told him that there was
obviously I mean when you saw the
damage in the house and everything the
blood everywhere I mean obviously there
was serious damage done
um I
there would be no point in lying to the
man he'd been through it with me and
and Mr before I told him that she had
thrown about a bottle of vodka and
smashed my hair
smashed
and cut my finger off the tip of my
finger
put a good chunk
I miss it
Mr Debbie you heard Miss heard testify
about an alleged incident of abuse on
your honeymoon do you remember that
I remember a testifying guy yes and when
did you and Miss heard go on your
honeymoon together
I believe it was somewhere in the
neighborhood of August
um because I had just finished the film
maybe end of July
um August
I'm not quite
good on the exact date
do you recall the year
it was two thousand uh
15 I believe
and where did you and miss her go on
your honeymoon
um
we we took the
the Orient Express
from Bangkok Thailand to Singapore
and while you and Miss heard were
together on the Orient Express
there were times when it was very
agreeable very nice
and then there were times when
um
something some something
had become dissatisfactory for her and
she would
start the
the rant the blooming of the
of a fight would would be on deck there
and uh
and and uh one
at one point
it didn't I mean I don't remember
lasting long at all I I just remember
that um
I I took a pretty good uh
shot to the
um
which is the face to the eye to the
somewhere up here
so I had a bit of a shiner
um but it but but the
it all went
ended and then everything got Fine Again
we'd go to dinner and it was all fine
did Miss hurt ever apologize to you for
giving you the Shiner
I don't I don't recall
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 162.
which is already in evidence
Mr Depp do you recognize this photograph
odoo was with the the yes the
um the chef and the maitre Dean the
staff were asking if they could take a
photo with us and they'd been very kind
they'd given us a
private dinner so where was this
photograph taken that was in the um
that looks like it's in the yes that's
towards the back of the Orient Express
that's in the uh the back train com bar
compartment and just out back you could
smoke on the on the sort of caboose sort
of
and
what if any injuries you have in this
photograph
the um
a little bit
bugged out
if you will
it's you
how did that happen
[Music]
um
these things could happen very quickly
if if
if you disagreed
Jackson You're honored non-responsive
she just asked how did that happen
I believe he was about to explain well
I'll sustained the objection
Mr Depp specifically how did the injury
in this Photograph occur um I'm sure it
hit me
is that better
um does this picture accurate accurately
reflect
what you looked like on that date
I don't look at myself much but it
certainly looks like me with a black eye
does this picture appear to have been
photographed uh photoshopped in any way
no I think I think no I think
that's a photograph I wrote to uh
started getting into sort of digital
processing with a number of people in
the shop especially in a wide shot
could we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1301 and this is a new one-year
honor so this is not an Evidence okay
thank you
Mr Deb do you recognize what's reflected
in this photograph
yes this is the
staff of the manager
and his staff at the um
um Raffles hotel in Singapore
um
before we left they uh they asked if
they could take a photograph with us
and when was this photograph taken
well that would have been we were off
the Orient Express we stayed in Raffles
I believe a couple of couple of days few
days
and then from there we flew to San
Francisco
so this Photograph was taken after the
photograph we just looked at
that this Photograph was taken after the
photograph in the dining car of the
train yes
uh your honor I moved plaintiff's
exhibit 1301 into evidence
oh happy honeymoon
31st of October any objection
no objection all right 1301 is that
evidence can be published to the jury
Mr Depp what if any injuries do you see
on your face in this photograph
I see much the same I I
see that
the the area in here has been um well is
is
swollen and
um yeah there's a bit of a Shiner there
thank you we can take this down
Mr debb do you recall Miss heard
testifying that she punched you
um in the staircase incident because she
thought of Miss Kate Moss in the stairs
do I remember saying yes yes I do three
times
yes I do
do you have any understanding as to what
misheard was referring to
I yes I do
um
as as Kate
Moss um Kate Justified
it was many many years ago
um
and what exactly what happened is
what she said happened
I
recall recall
um
speaking with Miss heard about an uh
that in that very incident
um
because of the down downpouring of rain
because it was raining very heavily that
day that Kate slipped
uh
and I recalled the story to her
objection your honor hearsay
please continue Mr duck what did you
tell Miss heard about the staircase or
with Kate Moss I'll make it easy for Mr
rotten born
um
Mr
took the story
and
turned it into
a very ugly incident
all in her
mind
there was never a moment
where I pushed Kate down any set of
stairs
yet she's spewed this three times before
objection your honor misheard simply
testified that she had heard a rumor and
that's what's the real answer to the
question sir hold on your
objections
overall the objection
sorry I was drawn by Mr rottenborn's
voice certainly what would you like what
was this I
so what what specifically had you
actually told misheard about
the incident with Miss moss and the
stairs very simply that she had
we were in Jamaica
um
I had left our bungalow
about three minutes prior to her I was
standing outside and suddenly rains it
was just coming down like it's you know
uh Monsoon and then I remember looking
and seeing Kate
coming out the door and there were three
little
wooden stairs and she slipped her legs
went up and she landed directly on her
coccyx and her lower back
so and she was obviously physically
in pain and she was hurt she was crying
so I ran over and
grabbed her to make you know to make
sure she was all right
um that's that's it that's the oh that's
all I ever
that's the whole story
but then um
the rumor of it
I'd never heard a rumor of that
before
um Miss heard
grabbed hold of it
like that sorry
Mr Depp we heard testimony from Miss
heard sister Whitney during this trial
do you remember that
yes
and how would you describe your
relationship with Whitney when you were
in a relationship with Miss hurt
I I
liked Whitney very much
um initially when I mean when I first
met her I liked her very much
um and grew to love Whitney
um
very much
[Music]
um
because I I always it seemed
Whitney Amber's sister Whitney seemed to
always get the
the sort of dirty end of the stick and
um I I felt bad for for that because
wasn't new
it had been there for for life and that
was that was
seemed pretty obvious
so I I took I took to Whitney
um
very very quickly very easily she was
she was a very sweet kid she was
wonderful
what do you mean that Whitney got the
dirty end of the stick
um
it was a kind of a strange combination
of
loving sister
trusted
sister and friend
and then Lackey
and then you know either
the punching bag or the dart board or
the recipient of
of some rather demeaning and ugly
um
words or
she would have wine thrown in her face
demeaning words and the wine that you
just referenced well the Amber Heard her
sister
and
how do you know that
well I witnessed quite a lot of it
um the wine and the
face uh
was something that happened in New York
which
I think that even made it into the
papers
I believe that even made it into the
papers it was in an elevator
how did you first learn about that
incident I'm sure you told me
in detail
what else did you observe of
um misheard and her sister Whitney's
interactions during your relationship
with Miss heard
they were just constantly up and down
but like you know
I could
I could sense I could feel that
Whitney
was
trying to please her sister trying to
be up to Snuff and
um
it just seemed like she got shot down
yeah it's gonna be on the scope of the
question or that his foundation for
knowledge that you're honor I I asked
what he observed you know between them I
think this is responsive to that uh and
his testimonialist of what Whitney felt
is oh sustain the objection next
question okay
did you ever see Miss heard physically
attack Whitney
I've never seen any
long blowouts
physical blowouts between them
tons of verbal uh
hello it should be on the scope
um
I I've certainly seen miss her grab
Whitney
push her push her around uh
there were a number number
there were half a dozen times when we
some of us whoever whoever was in the
General vicinity would have to leave
this is at Orange when
Whitney and Amber were living at Orange
Whitney and her boyfriend at the time
Sean Krzyzewski and he
we actually we had to leave the
apartment
and wait in the car while they
fought
and when you say fought do you mean
physically or physical
and when you said Miss heard would push
Whitney around do you mean that
physically Pusher or metaphorically
both
you heard Whitney testify that she lived
in Penthouse 4 at the Eastern Columbia
building for a Time correct
that is cruises
um how did Whitney come to live in
penthouse 4.
my recollection when Whitney first came
to stay at the
Eastern Columbia building in Penthouse 4
was
she and her boyfriend Sean had broken up
and
she needed a place to go
and so Amber asked if she could stay in
Penthouse 4 and I said well of course he
of course you know
how long did Whitney live in penthouse
for
um
it was well over a year on and off
did you ever ask Whitney to move out of
penthouse for
no I did not know
why did Whitney ultimately move out of
penthouse for
Jackson Foundation
it's his apartment your honor he was
living there
um
Whitney moved out of
penthouse for
long before the
um
marriage
and it was due to a
an argument that Ms heard and Whitney
had had
um
which had to do with um
Whitney working at the art of Elysium
with Jennifer Howell and those people
and understand
get out
where did Whitney live when she moved
out of penthouse for
she went to live with Jennifer Howe
your honor I know you anticipated having
a motion at noon you can keep going
how much longer in direct do you have
um I have a bed okay
uh Mr debb do you recall hearing
testimony during Miss heard's case
um from Mr Mandel
yes I do and and who is that
Mr Mandel is my former business manager
of 17 and a half years
who
has a certain point I um
uh discovered
had been um
embezzling quite a lot of money
so I had to take action against
him and he and and my lawyer 17 and a
half years as they were
uh
In Cahoots as it were
and
so so yes Joe Mandel is a
and they which was they
they settled
um
their case
um
they made their settlement
um
but yes it was it was the big that was a
very yeah Joe Mandela's uh
a very bitter man who ended up with a
lot of
money that I worked hard for over the
years
do you recall Mr Mandel testifying in
this case that you do not spend very
much money on charity that I don't sorry
that you do not spend very much money on
charity
Jackson your honor
excuse me okay
uh Mr Depp just to remind you my my
question was what is your response to Mr
Mandel's testimony that you do not spend
very much on charity
my response to that is Mr Mandel
is a very bitter man and um one thing
about that made myself personally
with regard to
Charity donations
sending money
to a charity
um
I I'd prefer
I don't I would rather that my name were
not on it I don't want the name to be
the
important thing or the thing that people
talk about
so when I donate a money
I donate without my name being involved
because I
because I don't see that that's
important my name being there in terms
of money now
if if I if I am able to
visit
hospitals or if I'm able to
um meet with Make-a-Wish children
um have held on to the relationships
that I've held on to with it in the make
within the Make-A-Wish Foundation and
the children's hospital and various very
solid places
then my obviously my name is involved
when we held premieres in Leicester
Square
for several films of Charlie's Chocolate
Factory and Beyond the scope of his
response to Mr Mandel's testimony I
believe this is this is in response to
Mr mid I'll over all the objection
so basically
when it be when it was a public
let's call it donation or whatever I
would talk to the studio I would talk to
Disney I would talk to Warner Brothers
we talked to whoever the studio was
well before the premiere
and make the premiere a benefit
that would
once we did what we benefited we did a
benefit premiere for Great Ormond Street
hospital we did a benefit a couple of
benefit premieres for the Make-A-Wish
Foundation
um
I mean
if you can turn a premiere
with that many thousands and thousands
and thousands of people there
into a benefit
um
it it works and it helps
um but it wasn't presented under my name
you know it was Disney's doing this or
Warner Brothers is doing this
I'm not looking for the um pat on the
back as it were if I can make it happen
great
but I don't need the pat on the back I
don't need the adulation I don't need
the attention
did you hear Miss heard testify that one
of the Charities she donated a portion
of your divorce settlement to was the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
yes
what is your relationship with the chla
Jackson your honor irrelevant and
um
um Mr debb what is your relationship
with the chla
um
I've had a relationship with the chla
for probably
or so
what's just the nature of that
relationship
um
well since since you know
sometimes there are
Make-a-Wish kids
who are in the hospital there and that
their wishes to
projection your honor yes
your honor may we approach
Mr Depp I'd like to take you back to
exactly six years prior to this week the
week of May 21st through May 27 2016.
um
what happened at the beginning of that
week
the 21st excuse me May 20th
May 20th
[Music]
um
this is we're talking 2016 here yes
um
May 20th um the afternoon of May 20th
afternoon evening
um my uh my mom
um
uh
made her exit
she um
uh she'd been
filing
cancer
numerous times and for many years and
she she fought
um
all the way to the end
and so my mother passed away on the 20th
of May
um I
which does bring instant perspective
into one's mind
I spoke to Amber that night I called her
on the telephone
explained to her that my mom had passed
that is who had passed and that um
I thought that the best thing we could
do
was to um
[Music]
well Mr Depp told Mr
did you move on okay
Mr debb what happened at the end of that
week on May 27 2016.
May 27th my daughter's birthday
May 27th
um
I was not in Los Angeles
I was on
the way to one tour and uh that was when
Mr
um
went for the restraining order
and oh yeah also there was the that was
the day that uh
[Music]
um
uh Alice Alice Through the Looking Glass
um a film I'd done
was opening
did Miss heard know that you were out of
town on May 27th
yes how would she have known that
well I told her I was going on tour I I
mean it was that was well established
how long were you going to be out of
town on that tour
and did Miss heard know how long you'd
be out of town
I I don't know if she knew exactly how
long I'd be out of town but it was a
pretty extensive tour of Europe
how did Miss heard's actions on May 27
2016 affect you
changed everything
Jackson your honor oh it didn't change
everything
until the objection please yes yes I'm
sorry
Tourette's
your honor this is one of the keys
foreign
Mr debb what has it been like for you to
listen to miss herd's testimony at this
trial
I'm sorry what has it been like for you
to listen to miss heard's testimony at
this trial
rejection relevance your honor
insane
it's
it's
insane
to hear
heinous
accusations
of
violence sexual violence
that she's attributed to me that she's
accused me of
um
I don't think anyone
enjoys having to
split themselves open
until the truth
but um
there are times when one
just simply has to because it's gotten
out of control
it
horrible
um
ridiculous humiliating ludicrous painful
Savage
on unimaginably
brutal cruel
um
and all
false
awful
um
I wanted
I
I
no human being is perfect certainly not
none of us
but I
have never
in my life
committed sexual battery
physical abuse
all these
outlandish outrageous stories
of me committing these things
and living with it for six years
and waiting to be able to
bring the truth
oh
so this is not uh easy for any of us
I know that
but um
no matter what happens I did get here
and I did tell the truth and I have
spoken
up for
what I've been
carrying on my back
reluctantly
for six years
I think you're I'm no further questions
all right
all right all right just okay all right
let's do that all right ladies and
Gentlemen let's go ahead and take uh
lunch this time do not discuss this case
with anybody and don't do any answer
inside research okay thank you
and don't break anything on your way out
thank you
all right so just a reminder that since
you are back on the stand do not discuss
this case with anybody to include your
Attorneys at this point okay if you
could just have a seat back there we do
have some other issues to take care of
um before we take care of
the third party motion can I have
attorneys come forward on our
Mr Tobin yes how you doing sir very well
thank you John thank you
thank Mr told me if you could just come
to the center
okay yeah
thank you sir
good Taylor's side
all right
good to see you
Mr Tobin if you want to certainly thank
you I got to make this relatively short
as you can understand but I I wanted to
take up your motion I have read your
read your motion and the Declaration and
everything attached to it in all the
cases
um and I have reviewed it so I'd rather
you not regurgitate that based on our
time limit but anything you wish to add
to that is fine
um if you wanted if I could focus you a
little bit okay thank you all right yes
sir as far as um your comments about uh
Virginia rule of evidence 2 colon 508
that's a criminal uh rule of Avenue so
that's not really strong not your
strongest argument uh and as far as what
goes on is when the uh or if the witness
testifies
um whether it's hearsay or it's third
party knowledge that's something I'll
deal with at trial so again uh not what
I'm concerned with as far as Supreme
Court rule 314 which I would like you to
to talk a little bit about that as far
as intervention and I got to tell you
where I'm at right now the concern the
the issue I have uh with the argument is
intervention obviously
would make you a plaintiff or defendant
in the case and it has to deal with an
issue that's germane to this case and
this is a defamation case so if you
could just tail your argument to that
issue sir sure I'm happy to address the
intervention for the record Runner
Charles Tobin from the law firm of
Ballard Spar yes you're representing TMZ
which is the publisher of news and
entertainment for the celebrity and
entertainment industry
um and your honor uh we're seeking to
intervene simply to protect the
relationship between reporters and their
sources when it comes to reporting news
in the public interest we as the court
noted we we really don't have a dog in
this hunt as far as Mr Depp Miss heard
we're really here purely on the the
First Amendment based issue of reporters
privilege and reporters and their
sources you're under the intervention
rule as the court is aware allows
intervention by anybody where the issue
is germane to the subject matter of the
proceeding and certainly your honor the
purported testimony the the prophet
testimony of a former employee of TMZ
who purports to be be in a position to
disclose confidential information learn
during the work during the operation of
Journalism during his work as a
journalist is it your main issue that is
being raised in this case and your honor
we would point the court to the Taft's
Fletcher Mauldin and Reed versus
Southern Bank and Trust case 213
Virginia Circuit Lexus 253 it's a
Norfolk Circuit Court decision from 2013
and there it was an interpleter action
the funds had been interpleted into the
court by two trust companies that were
fighting over it and the the man who had
sold his property who had no interest in
the funds themselves interplay
intervened in the case because he was
uncertain as to his liability for excess
funds which was an issue that was not
directly in litigation between the two
parties it was not part of the cause of
action between the two trusts fighting
over the money that had been pleaded
into the court the Circuit Court held it
certainly the rights of that man is
growing to be affected by the decision
making in the case he would be
prejudiced if he didn't have an
opportunity to intervene and no party
was in the position to assert his rights
and so similarly hear your honor TMZ is
a news organization it routinely accepts
information as is common in journalism
under exchanges of promises of
confidentiality if it is not able to
intervene in this action and neither of
the parties is going to be in a position
to assert the reporter's privilege it is
it is TMZ's journalist privilege that
we're talking about then the rights are
certainly going to be broken but if the
witness
and in all the cases I and I reviewed
the cases that you had in those cases
the witness was compelled to testify and
came and was forced to testify so there
was an issue about the privilege of the
witness it's my understanding this case
this witness wants to testify and is not
under subpoena he has been subpoenaed
your honor all right
okay
you're on Earth I have a copy of a
subpoena that was injured last night
compelling Mr Tremaine to give testimony
in this case and so he is coming under a
compulsion understand and if he takes a
stand and he searched some sort of
privilege then that's something I will
deal with at that time sure but I'm here
because of the scenario where he may not
assert that program right exactly and
that's why I'm saying all your cases
that you showed
were the opposite where they did assert
the privilege well it is it is a um a
unique situation right and I understand
you might have some some issues with the
former employees you have some Avenues
to go
um deal with that but once once he
testifies in the Privileges way we have
lost our opportunity
um to to intervene and just intercede
and you're under the privilege you know
I know your honor you said you read the
case I appreciate that yes sir but the
privilege it has been recognized by the
Virginia Supreme Court in the Brown case
and applied by the circuit courts
uniformly it is a very important
underpinning of the relationship between
reporters and sources and reporters and
the public without the ability to
enforce its Promises by current
employees or former employees a news
organization will have absolutely no
control over uh being able to enforce
its promises and so we would ask the
court to permit us to intervene and to
to assert the privilege that belongs to
TMZ which is the organization after all
your honor that would be responsible to
the source if this the privilege were
waived all right I understand Mr Tobin
your argument I appreciate it very much
okay the parties wish to be heard
a good morning you're after uh good
afternoon your honor um
I'd like to begin where your honor began
as the threshold matter the court should
deny TMZ's motion to intervene
intervention is not appropriate for the
reasons suggested in your honors
questions
as your honor is well aware intervention
is only appropriate with leave of Court
where a third party seeks to quote file
a pleading to intervene as a plaintiff
or as a defendant to assert any claim or
defense germane to the subject matter of
the preceding unquote
Virginia's Supreme Court ruled 3 colon
14. as Mr Tobin to his credit is has
conceded uh TMZ is not asking to file a
pleading
it cannot properly categorize itself
either as plaintiff nor defended and it
seeks to a certain no claim or defense
germane to the subject matter of this
action
moreover even if the privilege were
applicable which is not the case here
the testimony intended is directly
relevant and would outweigh any
qualified privilege quote an interveeter
must be asserting an interest that is
part of the subject matter of the
litigation unquote Hudson versus Jarrett
269 Virginia 24 at 32. here as Mr Tobin
stated TMZ seeks to protect a potential
seeks to protect potential information
solicited from a third party Witness
which is in no way a matter before this
court citing Commonwealth versus Gill 89
Virginia circuit 323.
a 2014 case denying a motion to
intervene where the intervater filed it
quote to protect a property right
not a matter before the court unquote
the outcome of this trial will not
affect TMZ and it does not have a
sufficient interest in the subject
matter of this suit to intervene see
Texas Fletcher maiden and Reed PC versus
Bank National Trustco 23 2013 West law
584-9140
granting uh and this is distinguishing
and granting the motion to intervene
where the interveners liability would be
affected by the outcome of the
litigation finally your honor TMZ lacks
standing to object to testimony by a
third party in this action because TMZ
as your honor pointed out is not being
compelled to testify
TMZ's Reliance on the Philip Morris case
for the proposition that the privilege
cannot be circumvented by seeking
confidential Source information from an
employee is an opposite 36 VA circuit at
one for one thing as noted in that case
there is no testimonial privilege akin
to that enjoyed under the Fifth
Amendment which would allow a reporter
to refuse to appear before a grand jury
and answer questions and Philip Morris
as your honor is aware the party issued
a third party subpoena for records to
trace confidential sources
Philip Morris is an opposite here
as that case uh related as as this case
is is related to witness testimony not
records as your honor suggested TMZ's
quarrel if any is with Mr Tremaine to
the extent that he had an NDA that was
enforceable applicable uh and that's not
what we're hearing from Mr Tobin so to
the extent that TMZ which is not exactly
Edward R Murrow your honor uh to the
extent they have uh a beef as it were a
cognizable beef it is with Mr it is with
Mr Tremaine it is not with Mr Depp and
they clearly do not have standing to
assert or to intervene because they are
not intervening as a party
plaintiff or defendant so we
respectfully submit to the extent the
court disagrees I can go into the
arguments why the privilege is
inapplicable but I will Reserve that
thank you all right
weigh in from just a different
perspective and that is because we're
trying to deal with some important
issues of privilege Etc but from our
perspective representing Ms heard we
have issues with this witness separately
and I want to make them very clear for
the record this is somebody who should
have been identified in Discovery was
never second of all it's not relevant
whether apparently what they're saying
he's going to testify and we have not
had the opportunity to discover that is
he's going to claim that someone leaked
to TMZ that misheard was going to obtain
the tro on that Friday and also leak the
video the the kitchen video with Mr uh
debt being rather violent
um and it I'm almost certain he's not
going to claim it's misheard so I think
it's never going to come in Mr hop I
understand all that argument do you have
any argument as to this particular
motion I I no my okay well then we can
we can address you my point is though if
you balance the Prejudice versus the
probative value I don't even see how he
can come in on Foundation or hearsay or
relevant that's just not part of this
motion at this time thank you ma'am all
right Mr Tobin your motion you get the
last word sir
I
appreciate that the court shook your
head when he made the snarky comment
that this is not Edward R Murrow
obviously the first amendment applies to
everybody citizens the New York Times or
TMZ
um and this is a first amendment-based
privilege your honor the uh Philip
Morris case is actually a very good case
to answer your honors question
um about the uh the the intervention of
somebody else in order to assert the
privilege
um their ABC was a defendant in the case
and it moved in order to prevent other
people the phone company but they were
already in the case in that particular I
understand there is no other mechanism
though and so I you know it would be an
interesting procedural issue for peel
your honor whether a journalist a
journalism organization or anybody else
who's the first amendment holder would
be denied intervention on a
constitutional based privilege
I also just for the record and for the
merits of the case if I understood Mr
Chu correctly he said this is not an
issue in the litigation this does not
relate to an issue in the litigation
well if it's not an issue in the
litigation if it's not part of a prima
fasci part of the defense part of the
allegations of the complaint if it's
impeachment evidence if it's collateral
to the main issues in the case under the
brown be Commonwealth decision under the
Virginia Supreme Court under the
application of that privilege in the
Philip Morris versus ABC News it is not
supposed to be compelled in this case
which isn't again it's not being
compelled it appears well he is a purine
by subpoena and it is a compulsory
process and he will have an obligation
unless he asserts privilege under oath
but it is our privilege your honor it's
it's not an employee a loyal or a rogue
employee's privilege to waive on behalf
of its employer this is an unusual
situation
um but the law but the answers are there
um in the law and it is it is a First
Amendment concern this is not the first
unusual situation in this case I can
for foreign
yes sir I appreciate you coming in today
and I appreciate your arguments yes sir
thank you all right in this matter under
uh Virginia rule Supreme Court uh three
colon 14 a new party May intervene as a
plaintiff or defendant to assert any
claim or defense germane to the subject
matter of the preceding a new party may
not intervene unless they assert some
right involved in the underlying
litigation a party is not entitled to
intervene merely because of byproduct of
the litigation adversely impacts them
and the decision to allow intervention
is within the broad discretion of the
trial court here the rights asserted are
not germane to the trial the central
issues in this case are whether
defendant to fame plaintiff and whether
plaintiff to fame defendant through a
theory of a curious liability the issue
of the confidentiality of sources has
not come up as in other cases cited by
ehm which is the the
the corporation at TMZ
belongs to is under their umbrella and
Brown versus the Commonwealth there was
an attempt by the criminal defendant to
subpoena institutions in order to obtain
the name of the confidential Source when
the author of the article was subpoenaed
she refused to identify her confidential
Source on the stand and in this case it
appears that the witness is willing to
State the name of the confidential
Source without being compelled
voluntarily whether that breaches a
non-disclosure agreement between Mr
Tremaine and ehm is not germane to this
matter and can be litigated in a
separate matter if ehm so chooses and
while breaches of contract must be taken
seriously and the court does any alleged
breach is not germane to the underlying
litigation here that contractual action
has no bearing on this case and is thus
not germane to this litigation therefore
I'll deny the non-party HM Productions
motion to intervene thank your honor for
the record I've known Mr Tobin for
several years I met no snarkiness at
story time you just a snarky guy
yeah
um your honor I am concerned that we uh
preserve the issue fully
um and so for the record yes for the
record and so I I would ask may I have
the opportunity to object when Mr um Mr
Tremaine is questioned question by
question no sir you're not a party to
this case however I will note for your
record your objection to his complete
testimony on behalf of your client right
thank you okay thank you
your microphone
as with the Hicksville witness your
honor I would ask that we could vadir
him before the jury
um to find out when he contacted Council
and when when they became aware of it
and I think also under the circumstances
In fairness I think we should at least
be able to ask him what he's going to
claim
response your honor I don't think that's
appropriate certainly I don't think a
profiter is necessary or appropriate I'm
not going to do a proper in this matter
okay all right
I know I'm so sorry
um but truly I truly am the Messenger
here because Mr Murphy uh just informed
me that he has to just clarify one thing
about one clarification okay all right
okay I apologize that's fine I think we
need Miss Myers
all right so Court will be in recess
let's come back at two so everybody gets
an hour for lunch okay
all right
foreign
foreign
all right you have a seat all right
cross examination
thank you your honor
Mr Depp I'd like to start with the
honeymoon that you and Miss heard took
in Late July 2015. certainly
you testify that you you took a train
ride from Bangkok to Singapore is that
right that's correct and you claim that
on this train ride that misheard
um hit you in the face correct
yes and left a black eye correct
yes and Michelle could you please pull
up px162
yes
thank you
Mr debb this is the picture that your
Council showed you both in
um your prior or showed you this morning
correct
yes sir okay and that Mark under your
left eye is what you claim to be a black
eye caused by misheard correct
um
seems to be there's some scratches
around my nose as well okay
all right but that it's your your left
eye the one close to the chef that's
that's what your you says your black eye
correct yes okay
um
and that was the picture your team chose
to show you right
I'm sorry which number was it this is a
new exhibit you're on in 1905. and
that's dependence defendants exhibit
1905.
ask for permission to publish your honor
oh you want to put it in evidence
okay any objection to 1905
um with the um comments we have no
objection to the photograph itself we
would ask the comments be redacted as
hearsay
well I'd like to at least question the
witness about
I have no objection to the photograph
being published okay well then let's
let's wait wait a minute Mr Deb you see
here this these are four pictures of you
right
yes yeah and and below it it indicate
that they were taken on July 24th 2015
in Bangkok Thailand projection lack of
foundation calls for speculation
in Bangkok Thailand so before the train
ride correct before the train ride
because you didn't get on the train ride
till the 25th is that right uh
somewhere in that area I guess okay your
honor I'd ask for uh permission to
publish this to the jury
uh with if it's just the photographs we
have no objects
photographs in it sure
we'll do 190 yeah 1905 but just with
reduction
I think there's still some on the bottom
I mean it's just redacta yeah okay
foreign
thank you Michelle all right publish
thank your honor Michelle could you
please scroll down to the bottom two
pictures there
Mr Depp in these pictures that were
taken before you got on the train ride
for your honeymoon where you claimed
that misheard hit you and gave you a
black eye you have the exact same Shadow
or sunburner mark under your left eye
the exact same Mark don't you
that's the um
when you get a side light you see the
occipital bone
so
that is the exact area yeah and it's
actually a side leg will cause that yeah
well the picture's not being taken from
the side is it it's being taken no no no
the lens in front yeah light on the side
right will cause that occupital phone I
believe it's called to to appear sunken
just like lights on the side of a train
car correct attention calls for
speculation you can take that down
Michelle that was in fact in the dark
systems people on either side I don't
see where the light fill is from the
side there Mr Jeff you can wait for the
next question next question next
question even the picture your team
chose to show you on that train
isn't accurate is it let's pull up
objection calls for speculation let's
pull up exhibit 1859 please
no your honor
Mr debb this is this this is the same
picture or the same
um the exact same scene
displayed in PX 162.
that you looked at this morning correct
that looks
like my face has been the eyes have been
photoshopped no Okay bye so this this or
this post from the eastern and Oriental
Express's Facebook page you're saying
that that's photoshopped
uh is that from their page sure why
wouldn't they let's pull them up side by
side please
you're on our move for the admission of
uh this exhibit we can just just have
the pictures we don't need the any
objection to the picture objection lack
of foundation and lack of Authentication
is that you in the photo Mr dab
it is me but it's clearly you're honor
has been I don't drink anything after
that first of all
and
um would ask for admission of this
photograph
lack of foundation all right
thank you your honor Michelle could I
please get you to you need to redact at
first we actually have have one
um it's that we'll admit or ask to be
admitted as 1858 uh that is just the
picture I already have each okay so
we'll call this 1859 then
this is so this is 1859.
yeah we just need to okay
we'll fix that exhibit sticker on the
bottom and get you that
correct 1859 1859
and Michelle what I'd like to ask you to
do please is to to put the picture
displayed as
1859 just
was admitted into evidence next to PX
162 that was shown to Mr death this
morning
you can pop those are both in evidence
can you try to make them the same size
please
this is the exact same picture isn't it
Mr Depp
with radically different quality
and
no you answered my question
you know it wasn't done you answered my
question sir thank you appreciate it
you're very welcome
[Music]
Mr Depp you had that whatever mark it is
whether it's a sunburn whether it's a
shadow whether it's the light reflecting
you had that same mark on your eye
before you got on that train
well it's pretty difficult to get a
sunburn on a train
and let's get photographs with the child
I don't look particularly sunburned can
we see those again let's let's uh pull
up exhibit uh one actually no let's
let's talk about Australia for a little
bit oh good
you testified that you've never done
ecstasy more than a handful of times in
your life correct
six seven times now you heard Mrs
testimony you've been sitting I know you
didn't look at her but you heard her
testimony and you heard her you didn't
hear her say you ingested eight to ten
all at once she said she came down after
being apart from you for some time and
there were eight to ten gone from the
bag a production form compound
I also heard Mr herzia reached into a
bag and threw them
and poured a bunch of yep MDMA down my
mouth correct correct that's right she
didn't say 1410 at one time did she
she's in a handful okay just more than
10 I believe okay the fact is Mr Depp
you are asking for ecstasy you who have
only done it six times in your life you
were asking asking for ecstasy and
cocaine within minutes of being admitted
to the hospital after suffering your
finger injury weren't you objection
compound
I don't recall that I was
like a lot of any drugs yeah let's pull
up a plaintiffs or exhibit 393 please
you just said you don't recall you were
begging for any drugs no I don't but I
do recall being in great pain and great
distress so okay I could have asked for
a teddy bear as well okay so this has
been this has been admitted your honor
this is an Evidence okay you published
and if you can blow up the text please
Michelle
in this text message Mr Depp
you are after you suffered your finger
injury you just testified you don't
recall asking for any drugs you're
you're texting Nathan Holmes your
personal assistant need more Whitey
stuff ASAP brother man and the
E-Business now we went over this in your
cross-examination didn't we
say if you say social and you and
Whitey's stuff is cocaine
I would say and the E-Business is
ecstasy
[Music]
can you pull up exhibit 1817 please
this is um
a picture that you were showed shown
this morning Mr Depp
yes and you kind of made some
illustrations on the picture and and
gave your account of what you see here
Mr debb you testified previously that
the vodka bottle that you allege cut off
your finger was a handle of vodka
correct
this bottle whatever it is to the extent
it's glass at all that's in the corner
of this room that's not a handle of
vodka objection calls for speculation um
I think you'll find that I said two
bottles well actually what you testified
to this morning Mr Depp was that the
bottle in the corner was the handle and
there is no other bottle in the picture
is there no that's not what I testified
I testified that may I touch the screen
yes
this
is glass
is this
is glass
and that's not a handle neither of those
are handles of Vodka it's that big it's
broken the handles up the top and on
those vodka bottles or yeah I mean and
none if you if you combine all that
glass on the floor that doesn't make up
the amount of glass in a handle of vodka
does it objection calls for speculation
there's objection hold on I'll sustain
the objection next question there is no
picture of a handle of vodka broken on
that floor is there Mr doubt
no I don't see it I see glass under this
chair here well
you talked about this morning that you
did see it so it's good to get that
clarification let's no I didn't do this
you also testified this morning that
yeah and I want to get this I want to
make sure that we're on the same page
here you testified earlier this morning
that there was no phone in the bar area
downstairs is that what you testified to
uh
I don't recall a phone in the bar area
okay I don't recall I don't recall a
baker light found in the bar area where
I okay let's let's pull up um Michelle
please the UK day three
page 421 Mr Devin we've we've we've done
this drill before this is your testimony
from the UK correct
can I please have
this we don't have copies for everyone
that's on the screen I would like to
have what he's the testimony of the
witness you can have my copy
Mr W you remember giving testimony in
the UK trial for several days correct
okay here yeah so I do remember a
telephone in the bar area
this is my turn to do this Mr I'm sorry
on page 421 line 19 you are asked the
question and this telephone that you
picked up was made of I'm sorry I'm
gonna go go up on the line 15.
question at one stage when you were in
the kitchen screaming Miss heard you
picked up a wall mounted telephone do
you remember a telephone in the kitchen
answer no ma'am I remember a telephone
in the bar area
question and this telephone that you
picked up was made of Bakelite do you
know what I mean by that a retro
telephone wall mounted but retro answer
it was a wall-mounted telephone but it
was not Bakelite it was a modern phone
it was plastic
question a phone that was a wall mounted
phone that was picked up can you scroll
down please
question a phone that was a wall mounted
phone that was picked up by you held in
your right hand and you were repeatedly
smashing it against the wall in your
right hand answer that is possible
but I do not if that is the case I do
not believe I spent very much time on
the phone I remember ripping the phone
off the wall that was your testimony
correct
it seems it would be yes thank you I
answer my question thank you Mr Depp
you've you've claimed before you've said
if I'm angry and I've got to lash out or
hit somebody I'm going to do it and I
don't care what the repercussions are
anger doesn't pay rent it's got to go
it's got to be evicted you've said that
before haven't you
have you a quote from me somewhere
saying that
it's my question to you you've said that
before haven't you well actually let's
refresh your recollection can you pull
up um the ghost of the machine article
please
possibly about paparazzi's
Mr Depp you see that picture of you
um
on the lower left
yeah just be shirtless and wearing a
crown I believe that you see that long
paragraph above that that starts with in
the mark Hotel uh yes at the bottom of
that
um does this refresh your recollection
that you said
I have a lot of love inside me and a lot
of anger inside me as well
if I love somebody then I'm gonna love
them
if I'm angry and I've got to lash out or
hit somebody I'm going to do it and I
don't care what the repercussions are
anger doesn't pay rent It's gotta go
it's got to be evicted did I read that
right
you did read that right yes thank you
you can take that down Michelle please
now
Mr Depp you've also
claimed that
um
you've said before that if if you want
to be with a woman sexually that she is
rightfully yours
haven't you
could you repeat that and you've also
said that could you repeat that please
yeah that if you want to be with a woman
sexually that she is rightfully yours
that's ludicrous you've also said that
with respect to women that you want to
be with you've remarked I need I want I
take haven't you
equally as ludicrous no can you pull up
dx883 please
there's not enough hubris and you need
to say 883 883
it is not admitted yet okay
foreign
these are text messages from you to
Stephen deuter's on February 22nd 2017
correct
um
this no this looks nothing like me you
might have mistaken uh Mr Depp we can
show the full under attack you've looked
at a number of text messages in this
case and the words him as the identifier
that's you correct in every text message
we've seen in this case
uh yeah sure it still doesn't mean it
hasn't been screwed with that's not
anything
that I have ever said or written you
want to see the whole the whole thing
I'm redacted we can look at that too no
it's because you could have typed it up
last night no yeah I can assure you I
didn't type it up last night Mr Depp
your honor I'd move for the admission of
exhibit 883. all right any objection uh
objection of
what
all right 883 in evidence as redacted
thank you Mr Depp are you're aware that
these are text messages
you can see the bottom right where it
says depth and then it has a number
eight one two nine those are produced by
you in this litigation you understand
that right I understand that's correct
either all right Michelle could you
please
let's take a look at the top text first
Mr Depp on February 22nd 2017 you texted
Mr deuter's right exactly Molly's [ __ ]
is rightfully mine should I not just
bust in and remove its hinges tonight
did I read that right
and the one beneath that you say I want
to change her understanding of what it
is like to be thrashed about like a
pleading mackerel and then in all caps
you write I need I want I take did I
read that right you read it right and I
did not write that okay
perhaps I wrote every other text that
you produced that came from you in this
litigation didn't you not necessarily
sometimes you give your people your
phone to people when you got off that
plane excuse me I'm from Boston that's
right when you got off the plane from
Boston you you knew Miss heard was angry
with you didn't you
[Music]
you understood her to be angry right
she was always angry yes and you asked
Mr deuter's same person you can take
this down Michelle please thank you same
person that you texted in that last
exhibit you asked Mr deuter's to
communicate with her on your behalf
correct
um I don't know what you're talking
about you have to explain you asked Mr
deuters to communicate with misheard by
text to speak to her about the incident
correct
about what incident to speak to her
about the plane flight
the plane plane
the Boston plane
the Boston plan
so you're saying that I
uh
influenced Mr duders I told him that he
had to write this and I had told him he
had to write that as I would just no no
it wasn't uncommon for Mr duders to text
to to communicate with Mr on your behalf
correct objection calls for speculation
um he was your personal assistant Mr
Judas was your personal assistant
correct I have two personal assistants
at the time he was one of them right
yeah Mr deuters was one of them
yesterday right and and it wasn't
uncommon for you to ask Mr duders to
communicate with Miss hurt on your
behalf correct
um it wasn't uncommon for any of them to
communicate uh with Mr Ed on my behalf
if I were on set or or
unavailable or any of that or if or if
misheard and you had had a fight you
would sometimes have them to communicate
with Miss hurt on your behalf correct
I think my crew caught on very quickly
that just just yesterday
necessary for them too now just a yes or
no it was not uncommon for having you
and miss her I'd ask that he'd be
allowed to finish his answer yes all
right go ahead and ask your question
again thank you it wasn't uncommon for
you to have
one of your personal assistants
communicate with Miss heard after you
and her had a fight
I disagree because you're insinuating
that I had them do it and you don't know
that
after the Boston plane flight you had Mr
deuter's
communicate with Miss hurt correct
when I'm asked what to do I should play
Kate or just play cater like we always
do and and you you told him send her
whatever message you need to send I'm
sorry I'm sorry he feels bad yes because
any other answer
you know it would turn into World War
Three okay can you pull up exhibit 229
please
okay
you're all right I think you know where
I'm going here and based on Mr Depp's
testimony I'd ask me for the admission
of exhibit 229. your honor I'd can we
please return
Mr debb you
you were pretty angry after misheard got
her temporary restraining order weren't
you
I was more than anything I Was Heard
and you testified earlier this morning
you claimed that you
you somehow were responsible for her
getting the role uh with Warner Brothers
correct
that's what you testify to this morning
you also
you also tried to get her fired
from Aquaman didn't you after the
temporary restraining order
which question would you like me to
handle first one question sir you tried
to get her fired from the Aquaman after
the temporary restraining order didn't
you
well what is related to the story about
me again just yes yes or no Mr Depp I I
don't know related yes I I can't please
you with a yes or a no every single time
it's a yes or no question you tried to
get Mr fired didn't you answers no all
right let's pull up um exhibit 821.
this is a this is a text message that
you had with your sister Chris
Dombrowski she was the first witness in
this case right she doesn't work at
Warner Brothers she can't fire Amber
this is a text message you had with her
on June 4th 2016 isn't it
um yes
your honor move for the admission of
exhibit 821 is redacted any objection
and your honor
21 in evidence
and on June 4th
2016
Mr Deputy you texted your sister I want
her replaced on that WB film
did I read that right
you did her is referring to Amber right
that's correct and WB is Warner Brothers
correct
again correct yes and then after you
sent this text to your sister
following the temporary restraining
order you reached out to guy Silverstein
to have him fire Amber correct who uh
Greg Silverstein I'm sorry
I don't recall reaching out to Greg
Silverstein you reach out to sue crawl
to get to the fire right I had vetted
Miss heard and I I have vetted Minister
Warner Brothers
we could just answer the question sir
next question you reached out to Greg
Silverstein to get him to to try to get
Amber fired from Aquaman didn't you
I reaching
excuse me asked and answered
it's a yes or a question that he hasn't
answered yes or no all right
yes or no sir you reached out to Greg
Silverstein to try to get Amber fired
from Aquaman
second half of your question is wrong
sir
because I've vetted her no no Mr Depp
you reached out to sue Crowell to get
her to to try to get her to help you get
Amber fired from Aquaman didn't you
no and you reach out to Kevin suzahara
to try to get him to help you get Amber
fire from Aquaman didn't you no
can you pull up exhibit 857 please
Mr Depp this is a text message that you
sent to Christian Carino
on August 15 2016. correct this is
already in evidence correct parts of it
are oh so not this not this version this
can't be 857 then don't don't 8 15.
sorry but he can't do this to me I'm
sorry your honor I understood
um we'll call it 857 a
857
okay
all right yes sir thank you my apologies
your honor
Mr Depp you sent this text to Christian
Carino on August 15th I most certainly
did okay and in this text that you sent
to Chris you know Christian Carino is
the person who used to be Amber's agent
and then was your agent for a Time
correct
that is correct and in this text
you
oh you're on a permission to publish
please would you want to put in evidence
yeah first move for admission of 857a
objection no objection all right 57 a
as redacted will be in evidence
thank you honor and in this text Mr Depp
you said she's begging for total Global
humiliation
she's gonna get it
I'm gonna need your texts about San
Francisco brother
I'm even sorry to ask but she sucked
mollusk's crooked dick and he gave her
some shitty lawyers I have no mercy no
fear and not an ounce of emotion or what
I once thought was love for this gold
digging low-level dime a dozen mushy
pointless dangling overused Flappy Fish
Market
I'm so [ __ ] happy she wants to go to
fight this out she will hit the wall
hard and I cannot wait to have this
waste of a [ __ ] guzzler out of my life
I met a [ __ ] Sublime little Russian
here which made me realize the time I
blew on that 50 Cent stripper I wouldn't
touch her with a goddamn glove
I can only hope that Karma kicks in and
takes the gift of breath from her sorry
man but now I will stop at nothing let's
see if malasque has a pair come see me
face to face I'll show him things he's
never seen before like the other side of
his dick when I slice it off
did I read that right you did
now not long after this you can take
that down Michelle thank you not long
after this miss you you met Mr Waldman
in the late summer fall of 2016. correct
I believe September October somewhere in
there or whatever and he's been your
attorney since then correct
yes sir and you met with him
with
The Daily Mail in London in February
2020 didn't you
I'm sorry again you and Mr Waldman
together met with the Daily Mail in
London in February 2020 didn't you
are you asking me a question about my
attorney and I
yeah that you two met with people from
The Daily Mail in London in February
2020.
was that during the
London trial
no
no
dirt in February I don't recall it
though okay to the extent Mr Waldman
testified that you did you don't dispute
that correct I just don't I don't I
don't recall it okay you don't disagree
with Mr waldman's testimony that you and
he met with people from The Daily Mail
in London in February 2020 correct
if that's Mr Walden's testimony then
okay but I just didn't necessarily know
who these people were right the same
month that the Daily Mail released
alleged tapes between you and Amber
objection calls for speculation like
personal knowledge I was sustaining
object next question
now Mr Depp you you testified and I
wrote it down before lunch you said
Miss Myers asked you something about you
know how does it feel to make you or how
does it feel to be here you said I've
been living with it for six years and
waiting to be able to get the truth out
remember saying that
yes he also said
I've spoken up for what I've been
carrying on my back
something to that effect you remember
saying that
yes and you've claimed several times in
this proceeding Mr debb that this trial
is your first chance to tell your story
haven't you
yes sir but that's just not true is it
Mr debb
that's not true
as
okay well here's the thing you you
the fact is Mr Deb
T when Dan Wooten wrote an article that
was published in the sun calling you a
wife beater you brought a lawsuit
against the sun in June of 2018 correct
that was six months before Miss heard
ever wrote her op-ed correct
I don't know and in the summer of 2020
there was a several week trial in London
against the Sun
correct was not a party to that triology
not my question Mr dab in the article
that the son wrote that you sued over
you sued for Mr Wooten calling you a
wife beater correct
objection as an answer sustained next
question and in the trial that you
subsequently brought
you called a lot of witnesses right
I don't know what a lot is I don't know
many people testified on both sides of
the trial correct yes many people and
many exhibits were introduced correct
like a trial yes and you just like in
this trial you were on the stand for
several days in that trial correct yes
sir I was and that trial involved the
same factual issues that you were
litigating here which is whether you
commitment illegal sustain the objection
next question you brought that case
against the Sun
because you were angry at the Sun for
calling you a wife beater correct
he
yeah that's and probably a pretty good
reason and you went through that trial
in London correct I didn't do yes Mr
debt you've already had a chance to tell
your story haven't you nobody
limitations in the UK trial okay no
further questions all right redirect
thank you
Mr Depp
um Mr ronborn asked you some questions
about
um the UK trial
why do you feel that this is the first
time that you've actually had an
opportunity to tell your story and as
you said get off get the load off your
back
as as the UK trial
was
me suing
down Wooten and the Sun for defamation
for calling me
a wife beater
[Music]
um
the UK have different well there are
different laws there are different ways
they handle things there are also
limitations
in uh evidence
um some things can be brought up some
things can happen
he's talking about
limitations and evidence in English he's
talking about his experience testifying
overruled
you'll be okay
um
yes the the the there is a very
um
everything is quite boxed in
with regard to with regard to what can
be said what can be spoken about so
uh
misheard provided information to the son
as their star Witness
but the
case was not brought against
brought against the Sun
newspaper Journal whatever it is
Mr rottenborn referenced that you were
on the stand for multiple days
four and a half I believe yes yeah what
was the nature of that examination or
excuse me who was conducting that
examination of you
um
QC social was and whose attorney was
that the sons
can we please pull up DX
857a
it's already in evidence
Mr adapt do you recall seeing this text
message when Mr rotenborn was
questioning you oh yes I do
can you explain what you're conveying to
Mr Carino in this text message
I mean
I'm in total
shock that this is happening to me that
my entire
life on the planet
has been brought to the head of a pen
with all this
um
completely
utterly false information so I am
yeah when you're accused of
horrific acts and things that you have
not done
when it's actually
some
very uh
ugly things that are going out there
into the world about you on a Non-Stop
basis
by Ms hurt and her team
you have a tendency as humans
to get very very irate and angry not to
the point where you go out and hurt
someone not to the point even where you
assault a cabinet
but
you do get irate
you do wonder why this person is doing
this to me so yeah many things go
through your head
um and then you've got your family
you've got your kids you've got your
power your my mom thankfully didn't get
to read any of this because that would
have killed her
but my father my
my family my everyone that I've met the
people that have supported me suddenly
I'm
scum
why
never had to happen
one little lie
so yes
very angry
can we please pull up defendant's
exhibit 821
Mr Deputy you recall seeing this text
message
um when Mr rottenborn was asking a
question yes he loves this one yes yes
would you care to explain what you're
trying to convey in this text message
um
well
Warner Brothers
was about to find they were about to
find themselves in quite a dilemma
as
the person that they had just cast
objection your honor lack of foundation
as to what Warner Brothers knew or
thought didn't I meet with them all
right
a good sweet for the question I'll
sustain the objection next question
Mr Deb without explaining what Warner
Brothers felt
why did you send this text message to
your sister and what excuse me strike
that what were you trying to convey to
your sister when you sent this text
message
honestly I felt responsibility for
having gone to those people
painted such a beautiful picture hearsay
your honor now he's talking about what
he said to Warner Brothers
please continue
change seats
so sorry you can continue
I felt it was my responsibility
to get
the truth to Warner Brothers about they
were going to what they were going to
end up facing down the line which was
two franchises
um uh
that would be
would be causing problems for one
another especially as
um
all the
any any news any press any media that
came out about me at that time had been
turned into you know I was Charles
Manson you know I was the worst thing on
on Earth and they just kept coming it
was like a it was like a Non-Stop fire
so my responsibility after having
painted a beautiful picture of her for
them was to tell them
um
I uh I think you better Jackson your
honor
it's getting into what he claims he told
Warner Brothers or wanted to he he's
he's saying what he he wanted to tell
them he's not saying what he actually
told them oh sustain objection next
question
Mr Depp you mentioned two franchise
films with Warner Brothers what two
franchise films are you referring to um
there was Aqua Net I mean Aquaman sorry
Aquaman and fan Fantastic Beasts the one
that I was in
and why did you feel a responsibility
with respect to those two franchise
films
um
starting to get quite
upset about some of the things that were
being said about me in the Press
that were a constant constant constant
hit pieces
um
and
you know it
on one level on one level
yes it's just acting it's just movies
but it's business and it's your word
and I've given my word to them
and I had to I felt responsible
in in to be that I had to tell them
exactly what was going on
and uh that it was going to end up ugly
and which of those two film franchises
were you a part of
I'm sorry which of those two film
franchises were you a part of
um I was uh
I was I was in a Fantastic Beasts
and where to find them and I was in
um the Fantastic piece the crimes of
Grindelwald
could we please pull up dx883
now Mr Dove do you recall seeing these
text messages during Mr ronborn's
examination
oh God yeah yes I remember
and you didn't seem to recall
these text messages is that fair
truly truly is
Fair it's I mean it's not I not
iced I don't know who Molly is I don't
know any I don't know nothing about this
do you have any understanding of what
you're referring to in this text message
for these two text messages no
no I I honestly if if somebody else had
borrowed my phone or something and made
this text to Stephen possibly
but I don't understand
the
I don't I don't have that kind of uh
that don't write like I don't have that
kind of hubris or
uh
expectation that's quite grotesque text
we take that down please
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
1821
Mr dab
do you recognize this document
that is behind the barriers
okay and do you see a Mr ronborn ask you
some questions about whether there was a
telephone yes in Australia I see a
telephone there now yes
and do you recall that telephone being
there
I don't recall the telephone being there
but uh I can see it now
can we please pull up eight uh
defendants exhibit 1820.
do you recall me showing you this text
message earlier on
uh
or excuse me showing you this picture uh
during your examination yes yes yeah
okay
okay
and
asked you whether you recall a phone
being mounted on the wall in the left of
this picture do you remember that yes
and what was your answer to that no
Mr Depp
Mr ronborn asks you some questions about
your your honeymoon do you remember that
yes and I believe you would testify that
you and misheard were on the Orient
Express together that's correct yes
where had you been prior to being on the
Orient Express
in
Australia
um
and then
made it over to Thailand to catch the
Orient Express
um if we could bring up the plaintiff's
exhibit 162 again
Mr Depp do you know who took this
picture
Malcolm Connolly
and
despite what Mr rottenborn and showed
you about the of the picture of you
prior to this
do you see a bruise on your face in this
picture
I see like what looks like a pretty
decent Shiner and a kind of a scratched
up nose yes
and do you recall how you got the
scratches and the Shiner
very brief
um
freak happens heard hat in our cabin
uh just before this dinner
I can't remember why there were many
um
I remember taking the photograph so I
mean I remember being there I remember
meeting the chef
but I I mean
the quality of the photos not great the
quality of the other photo that he
showed is
pretty pretty dope
Mr dab did you ever physically abuse
miss her during your relationship I
never
no further questions all right sure you
can have a seat next to your attorneys
thank you thank you very much
your next Witness
I didn't quite get that I'm sorry
stop calls Morgan Tremaine all right
Morgan Tremaine
foreign
testified truthfully in the case of the
penalty of law is it
yes ma'am
good afternoon Mr Tremaine hello
State your full name for the record
Morgan Cliff Tremaine
and what do you do for a living I
produce Esports events and design video
games
and in 2016 what did you do for a living
I worked as the field assignment manager
at TMZ
what is TMZ TMZ isn't an entertainment
news website and television show
and what were your responsibility
uh I was the go between the news desk in
the office and the reporters in the
field which you might know as paparazzi
approximately how many paparazzis were
you in charge of
time it was about 20 in La a handful
maybe three in New York and then one in
DC
and what were your responsibilities
specifically as to the paparazzi it
would be to dispatch
um Paparazzi to various locations based
on tips or um just Direction dictated by
having a list of sort of hot spots where
celebrities would be
and how were those tips received they
were received either through tips that
we received or tip line or directly
through news producers in the office
very often the case yeah
who were the type of store
they would receive tips from oftentimes
it would be publicists managers agents
or b-list celebrities
lawyers and lawyers definitely
how are tips verified
tips are verified by the extensive
process if they come in through our tip
line we have to verify who sent it that
they um that the source is truthful and
so they have to add their contact
information which is a field in that um
on that website for like name uh phone
number
things like that
and how long did that process typically
take if we receive a tip through the tip
line it could take a while because that
would need to be if it was a tip we
would need to verify it if it was media
such as photos or videos that would need
to be extensively verified to ensure
that the person sending it is the
copyright holder and that we would have
the legal ability to air it and
distribute it
and while working for TMZ were you
involved in any assignments related to
misheard I was
what was the first time you recall
working on an assignment related to
misheard I believe it was May 27 2016.
and what was your role in that
assignment for that it misheard was
filing a restraining order at a
courthouse in downtown Los Angeles so um
I dispatched camera people to that
location
only if we had been informed prior it's
not by any means a celebrity hot spot we
would only ever send people there if we
had been tipped off that something was
occurring and there was somebody present
there
and what footage was TMZ trying to
capture at the LA Courthouse on May 27
2016. we were trying to capture uh amber
leaving the courthouse and an alleged
bruise on the right side of her face
what was your team of Paparazzi supposed
to do while they were at the LA
Courthouse on May 27 2016. objection
your honor uh hearsay
and Foundation what were they supposed
to do right she's asking for I I don't
think there's a foundation I'll over all
the objection at this point
go ahead Mr Jimmy can you set the
question again what was your team of
Paparazzi supposed to do while they were
at the Los Angeles courthouse on May 27
2016. their objective was to capture her
leaving the courthouse and then she was
going to sort of stop and turn towards
the camera to display the bruise on the
right side of her face the electric
bruise
your team of videographer
we did
what is the difference between receiving
a tip from a news producer at any other
source
um if it's any other source it would
have to be verified
um by copyright if it was anything that
was received directly through a news
producer then they go through that
process to verify the source
did you do anything to verify the tip on
May 27 2016 related to Amber Heard I did
not
why not because it would come directly
from a news producer
does that mean it had been verified it
means that they had verified that tip
and deemed that it was credible and
therefore a camera person needed to be
dispatched
to Amber Heard yes
can you tell me about those assignments
um the next one would have been August
6th 2016 where um she was giving a
deposition
so what did you do in relation to that
tip I uh dispatched camera people to a
parking lot adjacent to a law office in
which she would be arriving to
so we could get the footage of her
arriving for the deposition do you
typically send paparazzi's
parking lots of law offices no not at
all
a shot of misheard on August 6 2016. we
did
after August 6 2016
were you involved in any other stories
involving misheard yes it was
and what story was that on the 12th we
received a video
depicting Johnny Depp I'm slanting some
cabinets that was captured by Miss heard
and what day was that I believe that was
the August 12th of 2016. 2016 yes
can you describe to the jury how you
received the video on August 12 2016.
yes the video was sent in through our
email tip line which is uh an email
distribution that goes to all the
producers and to myself as the field
assignment manager because it often
included celebrity locations the it came
in as as I recall a objection hearsay
he's just describing how it came in he's
I think he's about to reveal hearsay
you're right I'll overrule for now we'll
see where it goes okay please continue
so I received that email and included a
link
from some unknown Dropbox type
um
uh public uh website in which it
contains that's in your honor hearsay
he's about to describe what's what comes
from the Dropbox website and that's so
far as your studies what's a link from
the Dropbox we'll see the next question
go ahead next question
so you received a link what was in that
link in that link was the video of
Johnny Depp smashing the cabinets
and you received this video in your
inbox correct I did
what did you do once you received that
video
um do we downloaded it we alerted the
web editor who was sitting next to me at
the time
um we downloaded it and then we're
instructed by the news producer to do
what we call slap bumpers and a bug on
it which is putting the dun dun dun at
the beginning end and then putting a
translucent watermark over it which
indicates copyright ownership
after you did that was it posted it was
posted yes where was it posted it was
posted to tmz.com
did you do anything else related to
Amber Heard on August 12 2016.
um yes I received a tip that Amber Heard
would be arriving at LAX and so I
dispatched camera people to film that
exit or her arrival to LAX rather and
why did you do that
um I was instructed to
how long does it take to post a story
after
media's been received by TMZ after media
has been received it could take any
length of time depending on who owns the
copyright
how does TMC obtain copyright over
images and video
um the only way to obtain copyright over
media would be if we shot it ourselves
if it was sent to the tip line Source
verified that it was from the original
copyright owner and then either
purchased from that person or given to
us and then the third option would be if
it was directly given to us by the
copyright holder like a direct source
and how long does it take to copyright
something TMC has received through the
tip line
it can take a while because you have to
extensively verify that that person owns
the copyright and then possibly it
depends also if they you can even get in
contact with the person because they
might not be super responsive
immediately via phone or email that they
provided and then potentially you'd have
to enter a negotiation with our clips
and clearances Apartments to figure out
the cost of that media
how long does it take for TMZ to obtain
a copyright or something received
directly from a source
something in the realm of 15 minutes
just to do what I described before which
is putting bumpers and a bug on
something and write the article and post
it it's pretty fast
how much time had passed from the time
you received the kitchen cabinet video
to the time it was posted on TMZ about
15 minutes
did any other tabloids other than TMZ
post this video
calls for hearsay
did any other tablets
Mr Tremaine go ahead no they did not and
why not um because it was a TMZ
exclusive
and what does that mean it means the TMZ
owns the copyright to it so it can't be
distributed by any other media Source
without backlinking to TMZ and they
wouldn't be able to upload that media
without getting a copyright strike
have you seen the kitchen cabinet video
that was played in this trial I have yes
that was played in this trial compared
to the one you received on August 12
2016.
um when I had clicked the direct link
that we received and watched the video
at its entirety it was much shorter than
the video we had received than the video
that's been played in this trial there
was some a bit at the beginning that was
played here in which misheard is
um seemingly sort of setting up the
camera and getting into position and
then there's a bit at the end where
she's seemingly snickering and looks at
the camera that part was not present in
what we received
the TMZ edit the video no not even a
little
when we received something and it's
edited there's a clear indicator because
there's sort of a journalistic practice
that uses when there's an edit you do
what's called like a white flash
transition which covers the entire
screen with white to very clearly
indicate to everybody there was an edit
here for time or whatever
um just for to make it a little more
compelling but in this case it was not
edited as I was staring at the machine
it edited it and present for the
entirety of receipt to publishing
when was the next time you worked on an
assignment related to Amber Heard
um it was
well there was the time we went to the
airport and then the day after that um
because she had flown in for the
deposition because I think the first
time didn't work out
um so she was arriving again for the
deposition in that same parking lot
adjacent to a um a law office and what's
that August 13th 2016. that was August
13th yeah and what was your assignment
on August 13th 2016. uh to dispatch
camera people to that parking lot at a
specific time in order to film Amber
Heard arriving for the deposition
how did you know that tip was legitimate
uh it came from a news producer
well you worked at TMZ did you ever
receive any community
of Mr Depp or his Camp I did not
nothing further on across the Innovation
yes uh so
how do you know what
video was shown at this trial
um I was alerted by a friend that
um that TMZ was being kind of talked
about in this trial and so I had seen a
clip of that
so you watch some of this track correct
okay when did you first reach out to
council for Mr Depp
um I believe that was six days ago
whatever that date would be I'd have to
do that all right and then you received
a subpoena I think yesterday in care of
your attorney Cindy Hickox right correct
okay and Cindy Hickox represents Christy
Dombrowski Kate James Robin bomb
objection
speculation overruled were you aware of
that no
no
if you don't have information that's
helpful to this case then you wouldn't
be a witness correct objection culture
speculation
sustained sustain next question okay you
know this that you know this case is
being televised right I am aware that
there are cameras and so this gets you
your 15 minutes of fame objection your
honor argumentative I I can ask that
question oh ruled
um so I stand to gain nothing from this
I'm actually putting myself kind of in a
target of TMZ a very litigious
organization
and I'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate I could say the same thing by
taking Amber Heard as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly I find that to be purely
logical thank you now are you aware that
Mr Depp's attorneys were well aware of
the tro that was going to be presented
on May 27th objection calls for
speculation were you aware of that lack
of foundation overruled if you can
answer it can you restate the question
were you aware that Mr Debb's divorce
attorneys were aware that Amber Heard
was going in to see the tro on May 27th
I don't think I understand the question
I don't think so no okay
whether Blair Burke one of Mr Depp's
divorce attorneys has a very close had a
very close relation
ship TMZ at that time objection calls
for speculation
overruled
if he knows
I was not aware of that okay and when
you said that you were dispatched twice
once to film Amber for in a parking lot
for the deposition and then it didn't
work out and so you had to do it another
time how did you know it didn't work out
because because tmz.com posted an
article saying as much okay no I was not
dispatched do you know why
why I'd have to reference the article I
forget
I didn't write that story I wasn't
involved in the action journalism which
side do you know which side would have
known or not known whether that
deposition was going to work out in
other words the people represented Mr
Depp are the people representing Ms hurt
I wouldn't know okay
um and then the video Cliff
um
You Don't Know Who provided that correct
correct okay not justified all right
redirect
Mr Tremaine hi did you contact me in
relation to this case
um I saw that there was a discrepancy
with like the video that was shown here
in the video that I know I've received
so I I had no interest in testifying it
was I had reached out Simply to maybe
try to help with the timeline of things
or or help with the case in any way just
by virtue of of understanding the
timeline of the stories that were
published and kind of how that can be
unclear but I had no idea I'd be on the
stand
nothing further thank you all right sir
you're free to go thank you all right
you have another witness okay
Mr Deb calls Brian knew my story your
honor all right Brian newmeister
he has not been smart
anymore
[Music]
thank you
yes ma'am good afternoon Mr newmeister
good afternoon could you please State
your full name for the record it's
Norbert n-o-r-b-e-r-t
Brian I go by Brian
b-r-y-a-n newmeister n-e-u-m-e-i-s-t-e-r
um could you start by describing
describing your educational background
please my educational background well I
graduated from Cal State University
Northridge 42 years ago with a degree in
political science
um from then on I've been working
professionally in photography totally
unrelated for the past 42 years and that
would also include videography audio and
a few other different
binary related tests where do you
currently work
I own USA forensic
what is USA forensic USA forensic is a
digital forensics company we are
Boutique we're very small we work uh we
have offices in Gross Point Farms
Michigan and in Phoenix Arizona
uh we work with varying types of clients
because to us data is data and it takes
no side so we can be ending up working
for
a prosecution
defense law enforcement the Innocence
Project we have a contract with the
Department of Defense we do classified
and unclassified work we done classified
work with
various agencies we've worked with doj
I've worked in 23 countries as a
photographer
what's your title at USA forensic CEO
did you also found USA forensic
originally in around 1990 it was called
skymeister and that is because of my
they got a helicopter photography time I
have
about 20 about 10 years ago we changed
it to USA forensic while still doing a
lot of the same tasks
and you described I think some of the
entities that you work with what kind of
work do you do for those entities that
you mentioned we do audio forensics
which is clarifying audio for example
sting operations or audio that may have
been picked up on surveillance or any
other type of recording removing
background sounds video clarification we
do a lot of work with axon
checked on relevance based on the
discussion we had earlier this
experience has absolutely nothing to do
with anything all right do you have an
objection to him being moved in as an
expert in the field well she hasn't
moved yet I'm objecting to the relevance
of the testimony on the subject matter
right now I'll overrule the objection
thank you your honor go ahead and stream
to myself you can continue and we're
left off is we do a lot of work with
axon police cameras because they don't
really handle the low Lux levels or low
light levels very well so we clean up uh
we are beta testers for a program called
input Ace which is uh part of the axon
company used by police officers we
clarify their cameras to better see what
happened tonight uh for example in in
different scenes we do the same with
surveillance cameras any kind of camera
cell phone cameras
we also do cell phone forensics computer
forensics and cell tower forensics along
with photograph
photographic forensics what types of
cases do you work on it can be anything
from Fortune 500s to
um
it can be anything from a proper which
is a person that's actually just
representing themselves in a in a
smaller case to a lot of homicide cases
um
defamation
it could be any kind of case that
requires cell phone extractions or
computer extractions could be money
laundering could be a Department of
Defense identifying a voice that type of
thing satellite imagery and basically
anything with binary information
have you been retained as an expert
oh yes I would say we average about 150
to 200 cases a year in the last four
years we've done over 600 cases and that
would be in U.S federal courts U.S
District Courts various state courts
throughout
throughout the United States we just
wrapped up a case that was an overseas
case wrapped up yesterday
um
we do U.S military Court we have a case
coming up in front of the U.S Supreme
Court so it it's really very I've done
quite a few U.S District Court cases
have you testified
expert in digital forensics before yes
um and what people sometimes don't
understand is only about two percent of
all cases go to trial
so 98 of the time you're actually just
doing the forensic work and giving it to
the parties and as we say that is data
it really doesn't take a side we don't
have a narrative so very often it's just
providing the data for the attorneys to
work with uh or the parties
have you ever been excluded from
testifying as an expert regarding any
work that you performed no
um but you have to take into account
that sometimes there might be curbs put
on what for example in this trial
there's certain boundaries uh or if
you're working with a proper
or with a attorney that is not very
familiar with
electronics and and the thing is again
they teach Latin and law school not
binary and binary is the universal
language these days so sometimes in the
legal system it's a little bit hard to
explain to attorneys what exactly we're
doing so we try to break it down and
make that work
what is digital forensics digital
forensics is anything that you are using
like your your television set your cell
phone your computer uh anything that
runs off of binary information that has
coding in it
how long have you worked in digital
forensics well I actually started off in
analog so it's been 40 some odd years I
started off as a cameraman
um my first cameras were film cameras
when I was a kid my dad was a director
of sales and sales service
Administration for the NBC television
network on the West Coast so I grew up
around television cameras my first
cameras were
cameras people might not have heard of
Leica hustle blood cameras like that I
trained with some of the best
photographers around at the time William
Wallner Niall Latham really excellent
photographers
and
um
I started shooting videotape from
helicopters and I logged about 14 700
hours of video and
at that time oddly enough since we were
the only
helicopter a television helicopter we
were the only helicopter in Phoenix at
the time these the sheriff's department
did not have a helicopter
the police department did not have a
helicopter nor did Arabic so we ended up
doubling up
being a news crew as well as an air
rescue crew
so as far as forensics analog probably
from 1980 to 1990 and digital from 1990
through current
how'd you get started in it
really by osmosis I started in the
production field I usually don't do that
much TD work anymore I did do I did
shoot part of an episode a program
called planet Earth for the BBC last
year
I don't normally do television anymore
it's just 99 forensics
but
um I got started because very often as
working in the helicopter
um we'd be asked to work for a police
department in a rescue or a Chase or
whatever the situation might be and
since I'd be videotaping it they would
ask me to break it down frame by frame
and analyze it using what's called a
time-based corrector in the day and so
um word got out that I could do unusual
things because I'm pretty good with
machines and it
it just ended up it more and more people
started calling and it just became a
full-time job
yes but again most hackers and people
who do uh interesting work I don't have
any certifications because the
certification is usually like a
week-long course I've been doing this
stuff 42 years
my partner met Erickson he uh he's
actually a objection your honor to the
partner who's not testifying to those
qualifications on relevance sustained
objection yep Mr newmeister can you just
describe which professional
certifications you have received for
cell phones uh oxygen which is a program
similar to celebrate
uh but these are these are programs that
are used by law enforcement and by
private parties to extract data from
cell phones
um that has been deleted or
which is critical in a lot of cases
deleted data or just to what we call
Image a cell phone in other words get
every bit of data that's possible on a
cell phone and again every cell phone is
different the next would be in a Cell
power cell tower forensics
are you a member of any professional
associations in your field yes um IEEE
which is the international engineering
society and the reason I belong to that
is about 40 of the world's white papers
on electronics are published through
IEEE so they have a huge uh database on
anything from
microwave technology to telephone
transmission technology anything that I
might work with they might have a white
paper on it also with the audio
engineering Society AES I a member of
that I lecture to AES
um
there's a few others but again they're
just mainly to have a repository of
information
have you received any honors or Awards
yes I've received about 80 honors and
awards I have for videography I've got a
total of 12 Emmy Award statues but I've
been the Principal in 39 Emmy Awards
which means I've written the music for
the program and and the program has won
the Emmy Award for music but it was
given to the production company which
happens a lot I've won for best editing
I won for best Ace editing which is
um computer editing
uh just sound
I've won I've done the music to a piece
that won the gold Lion at the canned
Film Festival I've done music to a piece
that ran that won the gold at the
Calgary Film Festival I've got a lot of
awards from Associated Press and
different uh companies from doing
documentaries and news
have you published any works in the
field of digital forensics yes and
they're mostly articles about a half
dozen number so we don't have much time
and I don't usually do it but it was
basically on most of my work deals
around clarifying or authenticating so
it was basically the things I published
were on clarification of digital files
have you appeared on TV as an expert in
digital forensics yes
where
CBS NBC ABC BBC
um
Discovery Channel the number of
different things any particular examples
of things that you've spoken on TV about
oh Boston bombings how they frame
averaging was done on that sort of
things like that again we get calls a
lot but I don't speak specifically about
cases I just speak about technology
have you given any public lectures in
the field of digital forensics yes we
get office as quite often but due to our
schedule it's a little rough we do
what's called insa Court we do we speak
in front of private investigative groups
we do attorneys continuing legal
education
um
just uh auto audio engineering Society
just um
we try to do a few a year and that's
about what our schedules will allow
given our our
our time
your honor at this point I'd like to
Tender Mr newmeister as an expert in the
field of digital forensics any objection
no objection all right so moved
Mr newmeister turning to the work you've
done in this case um what have you done
I was asked to analyze the photographs
or photographs of reported injuries to
misheard
and what was the purpose of that
analysis to authenticate photos or to to
review and see if they were altered in
any way what did you analyze to to reach
your opinions well I analyze groups of
photos that were submitted by uh Miss
legal team
what work did you do to analyze those
photographs Well normally you start off
by looking at the What's called the exif
data the exit data is the binary data
that's encoded into a photograph it
tells you for example
um if the flash fired if that what the
operating software version was of the
cell phone or camera that that shot a
photo what type of lens was used what
the f-stop was there's literally about a
thousand lines of code in the exit data
on a JPEG photo so we would start with
an exif editor or an excess viewer
anything else that you looked at yes um
when we're dealing with
RGB cameras which are red green and blue
Channel cameras which would be a cell
phone or a basic home camera they're
based on RGB channels we would do
um four type four types of Scopes we
would do a vector scope we do we do a
luminance scope we do a waveform scope
and then what's called an RGB parade and
those Scopes analyze different things
the vector scope analyzes
where the different types of colors are
headed in for example it's broken up
into Reds magenta different areas on a
on a scope
we would
um
we would take a look at that to see if
there's anything out of the normal for
the type of camera being used in other
words would there be above a certain
percentage of chroma and chroma means
color saturation objection your honor um
outside the scope we can approach all
right one approach
foreign
foreign
foreign
based on the analysis you performed in
this case uh have you formed any
opinions
Pardon Me based on the analysis you've
done in this case have you formed any
opinions yes what are they well three
basic ones one is quite a number of the
photos have been through a photo at
least one possibly objection here on our
foundation which photos is he referring
to we have to go through this one by one
one's in evidence
yeah
uh Mr newmeister
in terms of the photos that you looked
at and that you formed opinions about do
you do you understand if they've been
submitted as evidence in this case yes
okay and what conclusions have you
formed about those same objection your
honor that doesn't cure the issue of the
objection we have to go through this
which photos is she talking about which
ones in evidence what exhibit numbers
that's That's the basis of the
protection generally about opinions
right now in your Runner and we're going
to get into some specifics I think we
have to go straight to specifics okay
um Mr newmeister have you prepared a
demonstrative that aids in your
testimony with respect to any of the
photos that you looked at in this case
yes
um I'd like to pull up plaintiffs 1303 I
remember if I might approach
your honor I would
again object we can approach the
discussion
thank you
Tom can we pull up defendants exhibit
178 which has been admitted into
evidence
Mr newmeister
um is this does this photo appear to be
one that you have analyzed as part of
your analysis in this case there were
many versions of this photo
um I would say there were dozens of
different versions with different
chromatic values different file sizes
different physical sizes some have been
through photos one or photos
three which are photo editing software
programs your honor at this time I'd
like to show them sort of Mr
newmeister's demonstrative plaintiff's
exhibit 1303 all right any other
objection I would object again your
honor because the photograph in 178 is
not in evidence or yeah I mean the
photographs and evidence the none of the
photographs these wishes to show the
jury earn events 1303 is an Evidence
over objection I'm not in evidence I'm
sorry as a demonstrative just as a
demonstration I'm sorry could we go to
publishing that's very pleased
and Mr newmeister um what is this
demonstrative show about the photos that
you analyzed well the they appear to be
similar however if you look below at the
file sizes uh one on the left is 712
kilobytes the one in the middle is 489
kilobytes
and the one on the right is 524
kilobytes now what's unusual about that
is these photos will not digitally
fingerprint with each other they won't
hash in other words forensically they
don't match but the thing is you could
say well it was sent through email maybe
it's a different size
this the file sizes for example would be
possibly uh you know you can select the
file size you send a photo but there's
no way to authenticate any photo that
was presented and the way the evidence
was collected
and so what conclusions do you draw from
that well there's this is just three of
many of the same type of photos that are
all different sizes and have different
chromatic which means collection your
honor we just had a ruling on this all
right sustained objection Mr investor
stick to your opinions that relate
specifically to what you analyzed about
the exit data please all three of these
photos had to go through some type of
transformation to change sizes
we can take that one down
you mentioned a photos 1.5 and photos
3.0 earlier I believe
photos what is that photos three and
photos 4.5 are editing programs that um
Macintosh or apple put out with their
product
it's for uh editing photos in other
words you would put a photo in
and you would change the colors or you
would crop it or you would clarify it by
enhancing for example the sharpening or
you could darken it
but when you save a photo through an
editing program you leave a mark on the
exif data and what is the exit data the
exit data is the data that is embedded
in a photograph that tells you a lot
about the photograph and again in the
early days when we were using film
cameras you would write down the f-stop
which is the light setting you would you
would write the type of lens you use the
time of day
um the type of film stock the type of
filters you're using now with digital
cameras uh that's done electronically
and there's about about a thousand lines
of code of which 50 are probably
important that tell you
what the camera was doing
so what's the significance of exif data
in your photoanalysis well in this
situation I can see that normally where
the operating system of the camera would
be which means the version that the
operating system the phone is running on
it would normally say something like
I'll just throw out an arbitrary number
9.1.3 operating system for iOS which is
Apple's iPhone operating system
instead of saying that it says software
photos 3.0 or photos 1.0 that means that
the photo had to be rendered which means
composited together in an editing
program
did you prepare a demonstrative that
shows some of your analysis of some of
the exit data of the photos in this case
yes I do okay can we pull up 1304 please
your honor me I wrote
permission to publish as a demonstrative
your honor any any objection
any objection Mr sorry she was used to
publish it as a demonstrative
um
no objections demonstrated all right
thank you we'll publish it is 1304
just as a democracy
and Mr newmeister are these images in
this demonstrative excerpts from the
report you prepared in this case yes we
are and what do they show on this
particular photo and on all of them it
shows the first few lines uh exif data
the ones that would be most important
for this Photograph so for example
things you would see the very top line
would be the make of uh phone it's an
Apple iPhone 6. and then the resolution
is 72 pixels per inch 72-1
and instead where it says software on a
normal iPhone photo it would instead of
saying photos three
it would say uh the software version for
example 9.3.1
and then you've got the date and the
time of the photo below that and which
is really easy to change in an exif
editor and below that you have uh things
like the exact like the flash you've got
the exposure type how long the exposure
was
so what you just highlighted there again
was the date and time so
that's a universal time code minus
whatever area you're in in the world
that's true yeah just below that if you
look there's some
um things that would say for example a
directly photographed image that is not
going to be necessarily accurate once
it's been through an editor it will
always pretty much say that so when
you're looking at scene scene type or
Auto exposure these are things that uh
that really don't matter all that much
what would matter is
for example if you're taking notes the
focal length would be important
um the pattern of metering things like
that to a photographer would be would be
important
and again this is just a few lines and
the reason I put these in there was just
to explain a bit what exif data is of
the actual thing I'm trying to point out
is the fact that instead of an operating
system it shows the
um
the editing program that was used on
this photo
um are there additional photos that you
did this analysis for yes many okay
um can we scroll to the next page please
Tom
is there anything about this photo that
you noted as part of your analysis Mr
newmeister yes again it's it's a
you know right right there you've got
photos 3.0 on that particular photo
and I think you know we pretty much
covered what what this is but again you
see the
photos 3.0
and again this could not come out of an
iPhone this way this would go into a
computer re-edited and rendered through
the photo uh editing photo editor and
this would then be embedded in the exif
data
do you have other photos in this
demonstrative yes all right can we
scroll to the next page
same thing you've got up here in the up
top you've got the uh the photos 3.0 and
this is uh throughout a lot of the
photos that are uh in evidence or
versions of the photos and evidence were
gone through photos 3.0 or flows 1.5 an
earlier version
let me scroll to the next page Play
Store
and what about this one same thing
photos 3.0 and again in a photo editing
app you can do an awful lot of things so
when you see photos 3.0 first of all you
know it's not anywhere near an original
there's going to be compression
artifacts because it's jpeg file
yeah a sustaining objection next
question can we move on to the next page
of this um demonstrative police
and again same thing uh you've got the
photos
app
okay and I believe there's one final
photo in this
um demonstrative
what about this one again if you look up
there it says photos 3.0
on that particular photo
we can take that one down
um your owner I have a little bit left I
don't know if you wanted to all right
you want to take our afternoon let's go
and take our afternoon recess just uh do
not discuss the case and don't do any
else surgery outside research thank you
oh right so let's let's just come back
at four o'clock all right
foreign
all right we ready for the jury yes
may we approach for just one moment okay
questions
all right ladies and gentry
yes surrounder sorry I'm sorry
um
thank you
all right
okay you can be seated your next
question
thank you
um Mr newmeister do you have another
demonstrative prepared um that shows a
photo with exif data reflecting that it
was saved in photos three correct photos
three years
um your honor we have a video of um
these photos and we're happy to play it
once so that Council can review if
that's all right
okay
foreign
thank you
okay
all right we took care of that you're
right thank you may we publish or would
you like to see it
okay and what's what's demonstrative is
this going to be then this is
plaintiff's 1305 you're on all right
thank you
could you play it
to your honors
all right so 130 marked as uh played as
1305 and new system to watch so you can
publish the journey
foreign
go ahead and play the demonstrative that
you prepared and then after the jury's
had a chance to see it if you want to
explain to them what the demonstrative
shows that would be great yes ma'am
can you publish
so Mr newmeister what was uh depicted in
that video
the same photo treated two different
ways one was marked with the original
opera or with the operating system from
an iPhone which is IOS 9.3.1 on that
particular photo the one this is 9.3.1
there's a graphic below indicating it
the second photo is marked photos three
and it looks quite a bit different
just Tom could we pull up defendant 708
Mr newmeister does the image in
defendant 708 appear to be similar the
same photo as uh what was depicted in
your demonstrative it's the it's the
actually it's the photos 3.0 uh edit
version
thank you we can take that one down Tom
um Mr newmeister we also formed an
opinion about defendants exhibit 712 and
713 correct
um did you prepare demonstrative that
shows
and show you if you'd like your honor
all right could we pull up
um plaintiff's exhibit 1306 Tom
and your honor this is another video
that um oh okay pause that please this
is another video that we prepared it's
not published yet so I'm happy to play
it once through
um
what uh exhibits are these that are in
this video it doesn't say I don't know
yeah I tried to get my question out a
moment ago defendants 7 12 and 713 your
honor
okay 1306 then we have launched it
identified
and if we could go ahead and play that
please
um Tom
and Mr newmeister what's your um what do
we see here in Mr monster
um there's uh exhibit 7 12 I believe you
have I'm not sure the Bates number was 7
12 and 713. uh there are two separate
exhibits except it's the exact same
photograph that's been uh one's been
edited one hasn't or I can't say that
one hasn't but uh the colors have been
modified in an editor objection your
honor uh beyond the scope of your ruling
talking about colors it keeps happening
thank you
um Mr newmeister um did you form an
opinion in this case about the
authenticity of the photos that you were
reviewed of Mr well first of all you
can't I can't nobody can identify
the authenticity of the photos of any of
the photos marked
photos three photos one or just marked
with the operating system number and the
reason is the manner of collection
so
these came from an iTunes backup now
what is an iTunes backup
it's not your honor I'm sorry you're on
the Scopia ruling exif metadata this
keeps happening neuronic may approach on
this one
so Mr newmeister um without going into
the specifics what's your opinion about
the authenticity of the photos you
received from misheard
based on the way they were collected
there would be Jackson your honor just
ruled on this
I framed my question I thought your
honor to avoid the issue that you're
concerned about Mr newmeister what's
your opinion about the authenticity here
there's no way for any forensic expert
to validate any of these photos thank
you very much no further questions
good afternoon Mr newmeister good
afternoon
your only degree is in political science
correct
42 years ago correct and you have no
degree whatsoever from any academic
institution in computer science correct
that's correct
and you have no certifications in
computer forensics correct that's
correct
from the opinions you've testified today
you relied on no data except for the
embedded exif metadata to support those
opinions correct incorrect
what other data did you rely on for the
opinions you've testified to today I was
trying to explain what other data did
you rely on for the actual opinions
you've been able to testify to today
besides exif metadata the type of
extraction that was performed you're
asking the question for the actual
opinions you do you testify to that is
what I would use I would also use Vector
Scopes objection your honor that's that
was not responsive to my question your
honor if you want to approach
sir you can answer that question
pardon you can answer the question
can you restate the question
uh
I don't recall a question or honor we
can move on your honor maybe we could
have the court reporter read it back
they could redirect
now what was the question Judy
I believe the question was what
methodology did I use to make my
findings Judy's voice has changed that's
it sorry is that correct Judy
okay
that's fine okay
so
when you're analyzing video or photo in
this section of video your honor that's
beyond the scope
all right if you could just answer the
question sir
when you're analyzing a photo
a digital photo you look at the exit
data
you use a vector scope
you can use a Pantone chart if that's
available and that should be done but
that's a whole different deal if I go
into that you'll object to it so you'd
also use a waveform scope
you would use an RGB parade you can use
a histogram though in this case it's not
really all that relevant
you are not offering any opinions that
any photo back photograph in this case
was intentionally Modified by miss her
correct
I'm just stating the fact that
photographs were modified but so you are
not offering any opinion that any
photograph in this case was
intentionally Modified by miss her
correct
that's correct
can you please pull up exhibit 170a
is that defendants one second defendants
170 yes your honor
so you offer testimony regarding this
Photograph during the direct examination
right Mr newmeister there's
that that's a yes or no sir
on the photograph like that I don't
exactly remember the uh photographs
there's so many different versions of
this Photograph but yes I talked about
that particular photograph but on uh do
you recall being deposed in this matter
yes you were under oath yes that was on
April 6 2022
I believe
yes sir
thank you
so um Mr newmeister if you could please
turn the page
76.
and when I say Pages those are the
little pages in the four boxes at the
top
and do you see page 76 line three
you were asked on April 6. anywhere in
your April 1st 2022 expert disclosure do
you offer any opinions regarding the
authenticity or lack of authenticity of
the specific photograph produced as alh
7101 response can I refer to my report
to see if that specific number is in the
report yes response not that specific
photo I just grabbed three out of the
batch do you see that yes
can you please pull up exhibit 517 or
defendants 517. thank you
you are not offering any opinions
regarding this specific photograph right
Mr newmeister
that's correct Mike testimony has been
limited here
and you are not offering any opinion
that any photograph was visually
doctored by Amber correct not by I can't
put the person uh who might have done it
well you're not offering opinion that a
photo was visually doctored by anybody
are you I'd have to see each photo
there's no way to authenticate any of
these photos based on what I received
foreign
about photos three do you recall that
testimony correct
photos 3 is a photo editing and photo
sorting application correct it's a photo
editor in photoshooter as is our number
of editors
so when you reference photos 3.0 you
never did any independent res um strike
that your honor
so when the when the software of a
photograph in the exif metadata says
photos 3.0 that could be just saying
that the photo was saved in photos 3.0
correct
unless you looked at a scope of the
photos that would tell you that the
parameters of the photo do not meet that
of the cell phone that it was taken on
but the notation photos 3.0 and the
software exif metadata that does not in
and of itself mean that the photo was
edited in photos 3.0 correct it means
that you've recompressed the photo and
it will not hash or digitally
fingerprint with the original photo but
it does not mean in and of itself that
it was visually edited in any way in
photos 3.0 correct
again it's not the same photo because
you're using lossy compression once you
save it so it you have changed the photo
foreign
so if you could please turn to page 233
of that transcript
and line 20 do you see question when it
says Exit software okay just photos 3.0
on to 234. that's just saying it was
saved in photos 3.0 right response saved
in 3.0 that's correct question that
notation in and of itself does not mean
that the photo was edited in 3.0 right
answer that's correct did I read that
correctly yes
a file has not changed visually just
because it has been processed through
photos 3.0 correct that's incorrect
can you look at page 128 of your
deposition please
the bottom line 20 question you see
question but the file change visually
just because it is it has been processed
through photos 3.0 answer you know
obviously I understand what you're
asking from a technical Point yes
because of the compression you get done
to Scopes and artifacts yes it has
changed was it intentionally changed we
don't know in other words did somebody
save it in there and just save the photo
we don't know did I read that correctly
that's correct
but again it says that was my question
mystery Meister okay
so if the XF metadata software field
lists the software as iOS you have no
reason to dispute that correct incorrect
well isn't data data that's what you
testified to right it's very simple to
modify exif data it's I mean do you find
any evidence in this case of actual
modification of exif metadata you can't
you can't authenticate any of these
photos because of the way they were that
wasn't my question Mr newmeister did you
find any evidence of any modification of
exif metadata of any photograph in this
case you didn't listen to my answer my
answer is there is no way to know
because of the way the files were
presented
so you felt but you actually found no
actual evidence of it correct that no
one could I'm not sure anyone else could
Mr do Meister I'm asking dude you
yourself find you you found no evidence
of any modification of exif metadata of
any photograph in this case correct no I
understand trying to control the
narrative but there's no way to answer
that scientifically because given the
evidence we're given there is no way to
positively or negatively answer that
it's not a question that can be answered
it is it is a question Mr newmeister the
question is did you yourself
you found no affirmative evidence of any
modification of software exit metadata
of any photograph in this case correct
you you found no actual evidence of that
did you
no one could tell either way because I'm
not asking everyone else machine advice
I'm asking about you
did you you found no evidence of that
did you objection you're under asked and
answered yeah he's not answered what he
found you're overruled
there's not a way to answer that the way
you're asking a question you have to
restate it and you're trying to control
your honor he's not responding to the
question you could use the answer yes or
no sir to the question
it's not a yes or no question did you
yes or no you found you found no
evidence of exif metadata modification
of any photograph in this case correct
that's incorrect
okay
it is your opinion that the metadata of
all photographs of purported injuries
that misheard has identified as her
trial exhibits do not indicate that the
photographs went through a photo editing
application correct well first of all
that's not a yes or no question because
a lot of the exhibits that you have
put up they're not photographs they're
screen grabs and they've been changed
from a apple format which is jpeg JPEG
to a JPG Microsoft format so you have
actually changed the exemplars you've
changed the data yourselves the we
actually ran
exif data on some of your own examples
that you've entered into evidence they
are not photos from an iPhone those were
edited in our PC
I'm going to uh hand up a page for your
disclosure
yes sir
thank you
thank you
so do you see on page eight of your
disclosure Mr newmeister it states quote
the metadata of all of the photographs
of purported injuries that Miss hurt has
identified as her trial exhibits do not
indicate that the photographs went
through a photo editing application did
I read that correct that's correct we're
talking no further questions all right
a moment ago Mr Murphy was asking you
some questions about your opinion about
the trial exhibits that Ms heard has
offered in this matter
um and he asked you about your opinion
that they don't indicate that they've
gone through a photo editing application
what can you tell us about that well
first of all this last exhibit it says
metadata not exif data so that's two
different things altogether we're
talking exif data and on the report I
put metadata because I was requested to
cover meta and exit data so it's taken
out of context the exit data is the data
based that's embedded in the photo
metadata can be the file data about the
file itself two different things
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that might be significant uh to say that
that way you can get on television right
no I had no desire to be on television
um I actually waited for a call and
wondered why I hadn't been contacted all
right but you but you only contact you
reached out and contacted them last
night correct yes okay all right thank
you I have no further all right any
redirect nothing further your honor all
right thanks Miss Leonard you're free to
sign off thank you
all right
all right your next Witness
your honor may we approach sure
foreign
ladies and gentlemen we're still on
track to have closing arguments on
Friday morning but the the plan of only
has one more uh witness and rebuttal and
then since we have a counter claim the
defense has a chance to have rebuttal
for their counter claim and so so you'll
hear the remaining Witnesses tomorrow on
that
um so since we don't have anything
further today I'm going to go ahead and
release you at this point do not discuss
the case with anybody don't do any
outside research and we'll see you back
tomorrow morning at nine o'clock okay
thank you
okay
all right and then for the record charge
the plane of the remaining time to 5 30.
the plaintiff has seven hours and eight
minutes left as of this moment and the
defendant has one hour and 16 minutes
left right so we're on the same page
okay and jury instructions we get clean
copies today
um yes your honor so here's I think we
just received their comments around noon
today but we've had someone not in the
court who's been looking at those and I
think has narrowed down
the areas of disagreement and either is
sending or has sent to Sammy uh an email
that sets forth a few remaining issues
of disagreement but unfortunately I
think we're mostly there but I haven't
had a chance to read what they say
mostly okay so I so I have everything so
I don't have everything quite yet and
it's not final ized okay but I will get
it sometime this evening
I'm
there we have an hour now I you can stay
in the courtroom and work it out how
about that that's we're happy to address
those I think I think we need an
opportunity to see what we I mean we
sent them our comments two days ago and
we just got it I understand but we have
we have some extra time right now so
nobody leaves until I get my jury
instructions how's that that's fair and
I like that okay we'll do that in the
verdict form also
and then
if I could read Sammy's handwriting I'd
tell you exactly what he said Sammy what
are you saying here
oh yes we got the three instructions at
under advisement so we'll address those
tomorrow as well okay
and we'll work on Sammy's penmanship all
right anything else
so to be clear as your your honor wants
to hear the disputes right now or
tomorrow we could I mean I I don't think
you know what the disputes are yet right
so I'll hear the disputes tomorrow well
yeah we could do those at some point
tomorrow sounds like we're gonna have
some extra time tomorrow so we'll take
care of those tomorrow but I want
everything today I want to know what
those disputes are and have what you
have clean and that's what I'm saying I
think that by five you're you will you
will get okay what the disputes are okay
for everything right okay so just stay
here until we get all that for
everything okay great anything else then
thank you